eh bien écoutez je vais essayer de me
présenter parce que j'ai pas le nom le
plus facile donc vanhemelryck donc le
prénom fabien dont je suis le secrétaire
général délégué pour l'organisation
majoritaire donc alliance police
nationale
je pense qu'on va intervenir en deux
temps donc moi dans un premier temps je
vais très très très bref je laisserais
après évidemment le syndicat des
commissaires s'exprimer nous ce qu'on
préférerait après si vous voulez bien
c'est si vous avez des questions et si
on peut vous éclairer sur certains
sujets notamment en terme de
fonctionnement ou par rapport à la
situation telle qu'on l'a décrite et
setra faudra pas hésiter
nous aurons en tant que syndicaliste
vous comprendrez bien que nous aurons
pas de langue de bois et en tout cas
nous vous donnerons notre version des
faits et je pense que celle ci sera
largement vérifiable maintenant en tant
que syndicat majoritaire
sachez que nous à notre niveau on peut
être que scandalisé par rapport à la
situation
on a fait tout de suite d'ailleurs et
vous l'avez là si vous le souhaitez par
la suite on a fait un communiqué dans ce
sens en disant que c'était inadmissible
qu on voulait qu'il ya une enquête de
fête chose enfin qui va arriver
ce qui nous pose problème aujourd'hui
c'est que on a encore salies et terni
l'image de la police nationale monsieur
rappelez vous les premiers les premières
les premières déclarations de certains
élus et autres on parlait de bavures
policières de violences policières et en
aucun cas on parlait d'un conseiller du
président de la république
heureusement que c'est pas encore une
fois de plus la salle la police qui a
été salie et heureusement quoi s'est
aperçu que c'était monsieur benalla
caché derrière son casque est déguisé en
policier
maintenant le le débat il est pas là
nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est que toute
la lumière soit faite dans cette affaire
notamment pour pas que ça se reproduise
de ce qu'on sait c'est la première fois
que ça arrive alors pas le l'observateur
mais l'observateur qui se prend pour
l'interpellateur ça évidemment c'est la
première fois que ça arrive on aimerait
qu'ils aient une convention spécifique
par rapport au rôle de l'observateur que
ce soit vraiment bien les fini parce que
c'est pas très clair des observateurs
savent y un peu de partout les
autorisations qui les donnent comment
elles sont effectuées sous quels
contrôles etc etc
et forcément un problème à bien
comprendre pourquoi monsieur benalla
mais là ça nous dépasse pour l'instant
en tout cas pourquoi monsieur benalla
s'est permis de faire ce genre de choses
on a dit on peut difficilement croire
qu'il était tout seul sur le terrain
un observateur et toujours avec un
tuteur donc forcément à prendre et moi
bien comprendre qu'il en est jusque là
on aimerait bien comprendre qui lui a
donné ce brassard police qui lui a donné
c'est radio police le seul petit bémol
qu'on peut dire c'est par rapport au
casque parce que forcément le casque il
l'a eu il devait l'avoir notamment pour
le protéger mais en tant qu'observateur
et ne pas notamment pas en tant que
fonctionnaire interpellateurs voilà
maintenant si vous avez des questions
n'hésitez pas à nous la seule chose
qu'on souhaiterait si vous le permettez
parce que la question revient souvent
c'est on commence beaucoup à parler de
nos collègues crs qui étaient autour de
cette de cette interpellation
on n'aimerait pas que nos crs nos
collègues servent de boucs émissaires de
lampistes si je peux me permettre c'est
à dire qu'il faut connaître vraiment le
rôle d'un crs avant de poser ces
questions-là ou même de les incriminer
c'est qu'un crs travaille toujours en
unités de constituer c'est à dire que
même s'il se passe quelque chose autour
d'eux qui ne les concerne pas
directement
ils ne vont pas réagir ils ne sont pas
là pour ça et ils sont là pour écouter
une seule autorité ce jour là c'était
leur hiérarchie directe qui prend les
hordes évidemment de plus haut après
dans cette vidéo ce qui est important
aussi c'est fermer les yeux si vous le
permettez et écouter les sons vous
verrez que ce jour là les crs prennent
énormément de projectiles on les entends
très très bien sûr les vidéos et vous
verrez que ils ne peuvent pas intervenir
et savoir ce qui se passe à côté en
aucun cas ce n'est pas leur rôle
et quoi qu'il se passe ils ne sont pas
là pour le faire voilà donc il faudrait
pas qu'à la fin on cherche des boucs
émissaires et qu'on s'attaque encore une
fois de plus amples qui est qu'on se tue
pas les droits merci monsieur monsieur
vous avez la parole oui mesdames et
messieurs et c'est heureux merci de nous
donner l'occasion de prendre la parole
aujourd'hui sur un sujet qui est
éminemment important pour nous puisque
c'est un sujet qui a porté à d'atteindre
notre institution alors effectivement
j'ai commencé par me présenter je suis
monsieur olivier boisteaux je suis
président du syndicat indépendant des
commissaires de police tout en sachant
qu'à 200 quatre commissaires de police
et je vais accompagner de monsieur jean
paul lemay gris qui porte bien son nom
qui est secrétaire national du syndicat
indépendant des commissaires de police
nous aujourd'hui on va effectivement
essayé d'être assez synthétique parce
que c'est pas l'objet n'est pas de
rentrer dans le détail de la ferme et de
recentrer un petit peu le débat ce qui
nous pas sur ce qui nous paraît
parfaitement fondamental dans ce dossier
et qui est quelquefois un petit peu
éludé par les différentes interventions
qu'on entend savoir qu'aujourd'hui ce
qui est important à notre avis dans ce
dossier c'est à voir quels étaient les
les fonctions l'émission de monsieur
benalla mais également de certaines
personnes qui entouraient monsieur
benalla dans cette affaire monsieur kraz
par exemple puisque aujourd'hui à
l'élysée semblerait pas nous qui le
disons il suffit de regarder aujourd'hui
les différentes vidéos les photos qui
paraissent dans la presse
quotidiennement que monsieur benalla
était certes le titre de chef de cabinet
adjoint à présent leur public mais qui
s'occupait directement de la sécurité
rapprochée du père de la république
était pourrie de claire son garde du
corps on le voit en permanence sur les
vidéos à moins de 50 cm et président de
la république donc il s'agit pas de se
cacher derrière son petit doigt
donc aujourd'hui ce monsieur qui était
manifestement chargé de la sécurité
rapprochée du président l'a vu même si
on nous le présente aujourd'hui ce qui
est assez étonnant
après avoir été suspendue comme
quelqu'un qui s'occupait des bagages de
la délégation par exemple de l'équipe de
france de football ce qui est assez
étonnant m'enfin bon ce monsieur avait
un titre qui lui conférait un véritable
pouvoir aux yeux notamment de l'autorité
que nous incarnons pourtant et c'est là
où est où le problème
je rappelle quand même que au sein du
ministère de l'intérieur on a un service
qui s'appelle le sdlp du service de la
protection anciens sphp service de
protection des hautes personnalités qui
intègre en son sein un service qui
s'appelle le gspr le groupe de
protection de l'après le groupe de
sécurité de la présidence de la
république
il y a plusieurs dizaines de personnes
qui sont chargées au quotidien de la
sécurité rapprochée des déplacements de
la présidence de la république ces gens
sont des policiers ou des gendarmes à
tête de laquelle aujourd'hui on a
gendarmerie et un adjoint au commissaire
de police ils sont formés aguerris ce
sont des professionnels de la sécurité
et pour autant on se rend compte à
travers cette affaire que on a un
certain nombre de personnes libyen 52
personnes parce qu'il est ressorti
effectivement monsieur benalla dans ce
dossier le sucre ajoutent à leur
peut-être d'autres je ne sais pas en
tout cas on a des gens qui manifestement
ont des prérogatives qu'on n'arrive pas
bien identifiés et qui en tout état de
cause de par leur positionnement et de
par la voix qu'il porte puisque quand
ils se présentent dans certaines
réunions il incarne la présidence de la
république
donc ça se voit conférer une autorité
naturelle sur des forces de sécurité
intérieure qui devrait elle avoir cette
autorité naturelle donc aujourd'hui le
vrai problème qui se pose à nous et nous
l'avons écrit dans un communiqué de
presse extrêmement clair c'est de savoir
si ces gens doivent exister ou pas mon
avis lui clair on a des gens qui sont
payés par nos concitoyens on a pu me
préviens quasiment 80 personnes me
semble-t-il où j'espère qu'ils sont
payés pour ça pourquoi est ce qu'on
emploie deux personnes si on emploie
deux personnes et nous en tant que
syndicaliste qui nous pose cette
question est ce qu'il ya une défiance de
la présidence de la république à
l'endroit des gens qui sont chargés de
la sécurité du président de la
république
si on n'utilise pas ces gens là il ya
certainement une raison et sont les
substituer à d'autres
donc il faudra à mon avis se poser cette
question d'autant plus que pour nos
propres collègues ça pose un vrai
problème
j mais je mets à la place de nos
collègues chargés dé sécurité du
président de la république et permettre
l'expression avoir dans les pattes en
permanence des gens qui se substituer à
eux pour faire de la sécurité rapprochée
un jour le lendemain participer à des
réunions de préparation c'est assez
étonnant donc bien évidemment la
confusion des rôles la confusion des
missions l'ambiguïté en tout cas des
fonctions de monsieur benalla et des
gens qui l'entourent dans ce dossier
nous nous pose de graves problèmes
sur notamment la lisibilité des
instructions qui pourrait avoir à donner
à nos collaborateurs
je rappelle quand même qu'il nous ne
rentrerons pas dans le détail de ce
dossier bien évidemment puisque ces
traités par la justice
il ya un certain nombre de policiers qui
ont été suspendus qui ont été mis en
examen
parce qu'ils auraient communiqué des
informations indus à monsieur bien là
pour autant quand vous avez quelqu'un
qui se présente comme étant directement
l'émanation de l'autorité suprême et qui
procède à des sollicitations auprès de
policiers
je veux bien qu'ils aient commises alors
peut-être je ne sais pas l'anc est le
dira et pour autant extrêmement
difficile de résister pas ce genre de
sollicitations donc le coeur du problème
les gens de termine c'est effectivement
de savoir quelles sont les missions de
ces gens là et ce qu'ils ont une raison
d'être
à mon avis non puisque eeel 1 j'espère
qui est chargé de la sécurité rapprochée
la prison de la république merci merci
monsieur autre intervention je n'en vois
pas je voudrais vous poser une première
question a manqué les rapporteurs à leur
tour pose des questions qu'ils
souhaitent vous poser éventuellement
certains collègues qui le souhaiteraient
aussi nous avons beaucoup entendu parler
ces derniers jours d'un projet de
réorganisation des services de la
présidence de la république
si j'ai bien compris l'idée générale
c'est celle d'une fusion du commandement
militaire du palais et du groupement de
sécurité de protection du président de
la république dans vous avez parlé et
avec l'idée d'une autonomisation accrue
à l'égard de la hiérarchie du ministère
de l'intérieur
est ce que ces orientations vous
paraissent positive de nature à
améliorer la situation
oui le projet nous avait été présenté il
ya quelques mois comme à l'ensemble de
la parité syndicales comme étant un
projet en fait accompli c'est à dire que
l'occasion de bilatérales on nous avait
annoncé qu'il y avait ce projet là que
comme souvent des projets présidentiels
c'était non négociable on nous
expliquait au niveau de la direction
générale de la police nationale que le
cordon serait coupé avec 7 unités là et
coupé avec le
le service le service actuel qui est le
sdlp pour prévoir et plus de souplesse
dans les recrutements notamment
c'est vrai que maintenant on parle
beaucoup d'une fusion avec avec les
autorités militaires de l'elysée mais
c'était aussi pour pouvoir avoir une
diversification des profils c'est à dire
qu'on nous parlait de contractuels on
nous parlait d'ex agents de la dgse on
nous parlait d'ex-militaires on nous
parlait de gens en situation de
disponibilité pour avoir tout un panel
de qualités différentes et
complémentaires arguant du fait que
policiers et gendarmes n'étaient pas
suffisants dans l'émission actuelle le
projet en était à ses débuts puisqu'il
n'a pas donné lieu à un projet écrit qui
nous auraient été soumis dans le cadre
des comités techniques habituelles mais
on savait que ça allait très vite et
surtout derrière il y avait une autorité
qui serait une autorité élyséenne alors
directeur de cabinet secrétaire général
sas avait pas été précisée mais qui
serait à la manoeuvre pour créer une
unité interne à l'elysée et non plus
dépendantes organiquement des des
structures police nationale encore une
fois les noms qui auraient dû être à la
tête de ces unités bien évidemment n'ont
jamais été mentionné on en n'était pas
là du tout donc tous les tous les
fantasmes éventuels qui ont pu surgir
avant on ne peut pas vous les on ne peut
pas il prêtait fois puisqu'on était
vraiment au tout début de cette réforme
qui n'avait été qu'annoncé qui sur
laquelle vous avez savoir qu on aurait
quand même que très très peu notre mot à
dire que vous voulez apporter une autre
précision juste une juste une petite
précision
nous ce qu'on souhaiterait s'il faudrait
pas que ce projet maintenant qu'on parle
nous auquel on n'a jamais été concertés
quand même il faut savoir donc c'était
vraiment
une simple information c'était vraiment
pas un projet abouti et en aucun cas on
n'avait été encore concertée sur le
sujet ce qui nous pose problème c'est
qu'on revient à parler de ce projet et
on n'aimerait pas que ce soit un
contre-feu par rapport à une situation
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on va pas
être ce projet sous prétexte que au
final le j'espère ne naît pas fonctionné
correctement
il s'agit pas de ça aujourd'hui la
police n'est pas entre guillemets juger
entre guillemets coupable c'est un
conseiller et je me permets de le dire
du président de la république qui s'est
permis de faire des choses qu'il
n'aurait pas dû faire le j'espère n'a
rien à se reprocher sur le sujet le
j'espère a toujours été professionnel et
en aucun cas aujourd'hui on doit parce
que il ya eu un problème le régler en
créant encore une nouvelle réforme un
nouveau projet ça c'est le don de
l'administration c'est que
l'administration le de régler le
problème
elles ne règlent en créant un autre donc
c'est ça qu'on souhaiterait passer à
qu'aujourd'hui ça fonctionne peut-être
qu'il faut perfectionner entre
guillemets cette unité et d'autres
d'ailleurs et autant en faire peut-être
un audit global de la situation mais en
aucun cas aujourd'hui
il faut qu'on mette ce projet sur la
table en nous disant que c'est ça qui va
régler le souci qu'on vient d'avoir les
uns et les autres
je remercie monsieur présidentielle
merci monsieur le président d'abord je
voulais dire la considération que nous
avons pour tous les fonctionnaires de la
police nationale et de la gendarmerie
nationale qui sont à dure épreuve et au
hockey en lesquels il existe une
confiance et c'est important de le dire
au moment nous commençons ses auditions
ensuite je voulais vous dire que
monsieur se veut dire général vous avez
apporté en partie réponse parce que
c'est vrai que lorsque l'on voit la
vidéo on voit des personnes qui restent
statiques de la police nationale et des
personnes qui n'en font pas partie qui
interviennent de manière assez brutale
et on peut se dire pourquoi
ou bien il ya matière à intervenir il
n'y a pas matière à intervenir dans ce
cas pourquoi les policiers
le font pas et pourquoi laisse-t-on des
personnes qui ne le sont pas intervenir
je crois que vous avez en partie répondu
et je crois que nous prenons acte c'est
pas la question de ce que vous dites par
rapport ce que j'appellerais police
parallèle il est clair que dans les
relations que peuvent avoir les
policiers avec des personnes qui sont
censées éventuellement donner des ordres
mais qui n'appartiennent pas à la police
nationale des problèmes réels ont pu
s'opposer
non monsieur rien non monsieur sur
connaît très bien la situation et
connaît très bien les policiers donc
c'est pas lui que aujourd'hui je vais
apprendre comment ça fonctionne c'est
important ce qu'il dit notamment parce
que en effet on peut se poser la
question parce que toute vidéo est
forcément interprétable et il faut
vraiment connaître et je me permets
d'insister sur le sujet il faut vraiment
connaître le rôle entre guillemets du
crs pour affronter réellement la
situation
vous avez des fonctionnaires en civil
qui sont aussi présents dans les
manifestations avec munis d'un brassard
police justement une radio et autres
hélas en aucun cas même peut-être même
aller plus loin sur le raisonnement en
aucun cas nos collègues crs savait déjà
que c'était un faux ou un vrai policier
personnes les avait prévenus et encore
une fois le ils interviennent que sur
hiérarchie et autorité directe et
uniquement par rapport à cette autorité
et en aucun cas avec une autre donc si
ce monsieur s'est retrouvé en plein
milieu de l'action si je peux me
permettre de parler ainsi
c'est qu'il ya eu un autre souci
ailleurs mais en aucun cas du côté des
crs qui jouera appel ce jour là la
manifestation du 1er mai était plus que
difficile 1 il ya eu je crois une
trentaine d'interpellations rien que à
l'endroit où il était donc en effet il
ya eu des blessés et cédera donc en
effet il faudrait qu'on fasse la part
des choses et je remercie monsieur soeur
parce qu'il faudrait faire qu'on fasse
la part des choses entre les
responsabilités des uns et les autres en
aucun cas la responsabilité des crs
s'est engagé sur ce sujet
merci madame jourdain merci monsieur le
président merci messieurs de votre
présence et de vos propos j'ai une
question pour rebondir sur ce que vous
avez juste à l'heure où est ce que ce
qu'on venait de déclarer à l'instant
vous avez indiqué qu'il pouvait y avoir
une confusion lorsque quelqu'un comme
monsieur benalla intervient ou peut-être
monsieur kraz qui se prévaut de
l'autorité suprême puisque il vient en
qualité d'émissaire de l'elysée en
quelque sorte mais en même temps vous
indiquez à l'instant que les crs ne
savent pas exactement qui est cette
personne alors votre premier propos est
une constatation d'ordre général
théorique où vous avez eu vos
connaissances par des remontées du
terrain que il se présentait ainsi à vos
collègues qui étaient en opération et
qu'il savait que c'était quelqu'un sur
le terrain qui émanait de l'elysée qui
était chef un adjoint au chef de cabinet
de l'élysée faut faire la part des
choses il ya la différence entre
effectivement les actions de terrain et
a évoqué tout à l'heure par mon collègue
ou là effectivement les crs aubisse
uniquement à leur autorité propre
d'emploi mois j'évoquais tout à l'heure
un problématique de sollicitations je
parlais notamment desquels deux
commissaires de police et du commandant
qui ont été sollicités pour donner des
images quand ils arrivent dans des
réunions ces gens là que monsieur
benalla par m se présente dans une
réunion entend représentant la sécurité
du président de la république on sait
pas trop où exactement quel est ce
qu'elle est sa fonction quelles sont ses
missions pour autant naturellement nos
collègues bas se sentent obligés de
répondre positivement aux sollicitations
après sur le terrain c'est parfaitement
différent on est dans une situation là
où l'autorité directe d'emploi notamment
des crs
cette année leur donner les instructions
propre poulain intervenir ou non c'est
pas du tout la même chose
merci monsieur le président et nous
avons encore huit minutes d'audition
vous êtes six à avoir demandé la parole
et par conséquent je vous demande de ne
pas dépasser pour vos questions 40 45
secondes pour vous y aider
nous allons mettre un chronomètre
et ça permettra que nous puissions
répondre à toutes les demandes de prise
de parole de les membres de la
commission des lois
donc monsieur tout d'abord monsieur
richard qui est le premier je crois
avoir demandé la parole l'un de vous
messieurs a évoqué le fait que lors des
déplacements du président vous pensiez
vous pouviez penser qu'il y avait
plusieurs personnes s'interposant autour
du gspr en dehors de monsieur benalla
est-ce que vous avez des indices précis
qui ferait apparaître qu'en effet il y
aurait un groupe de personnes
constituant une garde personnel en
dehors du gspr merci monsieur richard de
votre concision monsieur marseille oui
merci monsieur le président messieurs on
voit nettement que monsieur benalla
disposer d'un téléphone un accès au
réseau
est ce que c'est le réseau acropole dans
ces cas là est-ce qu'il a enregistrés et
donc est ce qu'on peut avoir accès aux
enregistrements
merci monsieur marseille monsieur k mr
le président nos amis ici présent nous
nous disent que toute vidéo est
interprétable la question est très
direct très simple puisque la défense de
monsieur benalla ainsi sur le fait que
monsieur ghana est venu donner un coup
de main à des forces de police débordée
par la situation est ce que vous
considérez que ses forces étaient
débordées par la situation au regard de
ce qu'ils ont pu découvrir sur la vidéo
merci monsieur présidente kaner madame
benbassa merci monsieur le président
chers à porter
chers collègues je voudrais savoir
quelles étaient les relations entre les
policiers à la sécurité à l'elysée
et monsieur benalla parce qu'il n'a pas
pu quand même avec tous ses équipements
de police
cette présence si importante sur place
donc j'aimerais savoir un peu merci
madame benbassa je suis grosdidier
je vais aller d'autant plus vite que
j'avais deux questions la première on
parle toujours de son statut
d'observateur mais ce qu'il n'ya pas
aussi en opération le dire des
fonctionnaires d'autorité
j'ai été présenté comme chef adjoint de
cabinet mais on a souvent la
manifestation des membres du corps
préfectoral
il ya parfois dans les préfectures un
directeur de la sécurité qui n'est que
qu'attaché préfecture donc y at il une
doctrine partir de quand des
fonctionnaires de l'état voire des
contractuels peuvent ou ne peuvent pas
donner des ordres directement à des
fonctionnaires sur le terrain
la deuxième question c'est sûr c'est sur
la vidéo certes les images sont
interprétable mais elle donne des
éléments objectifs
est-ce que les opérations de maintien de
l'ordre sont globalement filmer est ce
qu'avec les progrès de la vidéo il ya eu
une évolution vers des prises de vidéos
plus systématique et enfin effectivement
monsieur mellala invoque l'article 73
qui permet à tout citoyen d'intervenir
en cas de flagrant délit pour
interpeller personne a déposé a loupé
jsk en l'occurrence et les vidéos
donnent un fondement veut dire à cet
argument de défense
je vous remercie cher que les madame
arriver merci monsieur le président la
question est très simple on a parlé de
d'éléments distinctifs sur le rôle de
chacun
est ce qu'il existe des éléments
distinctifs pour un observateur et quel
régime exact de conduite et
d'accompagnement de ces observateurs
merci
madame marie b madame lherbier oui
messieurs
moi ma question porte aussi sur les
vidéos vous avez parlé de sollicitations
pour donner des images
j'aimerais savoir si ce sont les
originaux s'il ya eu des copies ou si on
y reste encore d'autres images à
découvrir
gevo merci et madame dernier et comme
membre d'honneur de la commission des
lois à titre dérogatoire madaba sassi
qui demande la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président une
question puisque d'autres ont déjà été
posée il ya le monsieur mini de
l'intérieur a répondu à plusieurs
reprises que l'igpn avait été saisie
s'agissant d'enquêtés sur monsieur
benalla or ce monsieur n'est ni policier
ni gendarme ne pensez vous pas qu'il
aurait mieux valu saisir liga dans ces
cas là bien monsieur le secrétaire
général messieurs vous avez quelques
minutes pour répondre sur vous remercie
mes collègues qui font preuve d'un
esprit vraiment de concision qui est
vraiment digne de tous les éloges mais
je crois que si on veut permettre à
chacun de poser des questions il faut
procéder ainsi alors on va ici vous
réponds très très rapidement moi je
pourrais vous répondre sur les relations
justement avec nos collègues de là ces
jeunes notamment sachez que ces
relations étaient très très mauvaise
malgré moi je parle au nom des collègues
gradés et gardiens attention elle était
très très mauvaise
d'ailleurs monsieur benalla sans être
dans les caricatures était d'après les
termes de mes collègues étaient
exécrables donc montrer vraiment ses
fonctions et son identité et avaient du
mal à comprendre que parfois il fallait
attendre de pouvoir passer ou bave
attendre pour pouvoir se garer etc etc
sur la deuxième chose sur l'observateur
c'est pour ça qu'on demande justement
une vraie doctrine une vraie convention
parce que malheureusement à notre
connaissance il n'y en a pas donc on
aimerait bien comprendre une bonne fois
pour toute et avoir le même schéma pour
tout le monde pascal observateurs
peuvent venir peut venir de n'importe
quel milieu donc ça ça peut être très
intéressant et nous sommes même plutôt
favorable parce que ça permet d'avoir
une vision extérieure de la police et
comme la police n'a rien à cacher et m'a
coûté c'est plutôt une bonne chose ça
permet aussi d'avoir une année gliese
fine et ça permet aussi de découvrir nos
conditions de travail qui sont pas
qu'ils sont loin d'être facile encore
faut-il avoir vraiment une convention
définit et ça je pense que c'est même
essentiel concernant les crs je
laisserai la parole à monsieur cac valeo
s'est cavallero pour les crs ont au
sujet de l'adaptation sur le sur le site
en fait tant que pour être rapide les
collègues dans ce qu'on appelle la spi
c'est la section de protection et
d'intervention veille de sortie pour
pour interpeller l'individu qui était
enfin qu'ils étaient auteurs de jets de
projectiles
ensuite ils le remettent à des
défenseurs qui pour eux était défenseur
de police
nos six importants à savoir ensuite pour
les crs et de revenir sur leur mission
initiale de garder le terrain parce que
la mission première est de rétablir
l'ordre public maintient moment ils
prennent ils interpellent ils remettent
à une autre des autres effectif pour
tenir le terrain cela place quant aux
cartes sur lesquelles il faisait l'objet
de beaucoup de jets de projectiles où il
ya eu des blessés
voilà ça c'était le rôle de la mission
des crs et de rétablir l'ordre public
pour la deuxième chose il a agi sur
instruction de l'autorité civile donc
pas d'attaché ou autre c'est soit le
préfet ou le commissaire de police il ya
des sommations ça s'écrit dans les
comptes rendus des des crs
et pour répondre sur les vidéos là aussi
il chaque compagnie de crs est doté de
moyens photo vidéo soit ils peuvent le
mettre en action ou pas sans les
circonstances
en tout cas pour la série s qui est
concerné il y avait des moyens vidéos
qui ont été mis en place s'est mis dans
ces petits mots ou des photos et tout ce
qui est sommation tout était mis sur
compte rendu voilà donc tout était clair
et transparent transmis par la crs qui
étaient sur le terrain au moment des
faits si je peux me permettre c'est
aussi une question sur les radios et les
si on avait des death on lui demande si
monsieur pénale avait parlé avec un un
système acropole
d'après nos informations tous les
enregistrements radio dure soixante deux
jours donc forcément le délai est un peu
dépassée et sur les vidéos normalement
on est on est enfin on est à 30 jours
donc 62 jours à la radio ça devrait
pouvoir peut-être encore se trouver mais
je crois que monsieur gibelin a répondu
à cette question hier lors de l'audition
et sur les sur les vidéos on est sensé
je préfère parler comme ça on est censé
ne pas en trouver d'autres
il me semble lier que le préfet de
police a répondu en expliquant qu
effectivement il y avait dix vidéos qui
avaient été retrouvés qui n'auraient pas
dû l'être puisque le délai était
largement dépassé donc la réponse a été
donnée
je vais m'en fait que l'écho je vous
remercie d'autres éléments de réponse
est bien un positionnement à propos du
traitement de monsieur benalla par
l'igpn
en fait c'est une une convention de
langage puisqu'en fait il ya deux
services qui ont été cosaisis dans cette
affaire
les gardes à vue deux de nos collègues
ont été traités par l'inspection
générale de la police nationale
mais la situation de monsieur de
monsieur kraz et de monsieur benalla a
été traité par un service très
particulier de la police judiciaire de
paris qui s'appelle la brigade de
répression de la délinquance aux
personnes qui est qui a une multitude de
compétences dont les abus de fonction
les abus d'autorité
donc qui a été saisie par le parquet de
paris
et ce n'est que en bout de garde à vue
des uns comme des autres que tout à été
regroupés dans une même commission
rogatoire mais à moins que ça soit
quelque chose de conex la plupart du
temps l'igpn traite les problématiques
liées à des policiers et laisse d'autres
services par le biais notamment de co
saisine se sait ce s'intéresser plus
particulièrement aux autres personnes
quand elles sont dans la même affaire
mais évidemment les deux services se
parlent pour être le plus efficace
possible on peut avoir des exemples avec
dd quand on a des domaines techniques
pointues par exemple un domaine
informatique on va saisir un service
informatique qui va être très
particulier à l'appui l'igpn
merci cette audi sur à monsieur richard
savoir si à votre connaissance
si vous disposiez d'un indice substance
faisant supposer qu'il y avait d'autres
personnes que monsieur benalla qui
s'ajoutait au gspm mais pas eu la
réponse non nous n'avons pas mais nous
n'avons pas d'indicés particuliers
simplement nous voyons sur les vidéos où
tout le monde qu'il y avait monsieur
mais n'a là qu'il y avait monsieur crasé
néanmoins de
ensuite ces avancées fait on connaissait
même pas le nom ni de monsieur mba là
monsieur crâne ne manque une relation
directe km pour l'instant il lui s'est
avéré par les vidéos uniquement si cette
audition est donc terminée et nous
allons passer immédiatement à l'audition
suivante
il est très intéressante
bien messieurs s'il vous plaît prenez et
madame prenez place
nous commençons donc cette audition avec
la fédération de la cfdt demande de bien
vouloir gagner votre siège
même monsieur nous allons vous proposer
de faire une déclaration liminaire que
vous organisez comme vous le souhaitez
sachez que nous n'avons qu'une
demi-heure et qu' il est souhaitable que
vous permettiez à nos collègues
rapporteur ou sénateur membre de la
commission des lois de poser quelques
questions que leur inspire on vos propos
donc je vous laisse la parole celui
d'entre vous qui veulent apprendre la
saisie merci monsieur le président que
rapidement la cfdt est une instance au
sein du mr l'intérieur qui est très peu
représentée jusqu'à ce jour je tiens à
le signaler
vous avez ici denis jacob qui le
secrétaire général de la partie gardiens
de la paix pour alternatif police et en
l'occurrence nous qui représentons
syndicat des cadres la sécurité
intérieure des officiers et des
commissaires de police puisque nous
pensons que fondamentalement il faut que
au sein de ce ministère
les sujets sortent du purement
catégorielles ce que je vous interromps
marc mais c'est vrai que cette audition
se déroule dans des conditions
particulières nous somme investie des
pouvoirs d'une commission d'enquêté nous
devons vous faire prêter serment je vais
en prendre l'habitude pour les auditions
successives
je rappelle qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission des lois doté de ses
prérogatives serait passible de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
demande je vous invite à prêter serment
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité levé la main droite et dit je le
jure je le jure je vous remercie et
reprenez votre propos a donc pour notre
confédération
nous souhaitons à l'aune de cette
affaire met en avant qu'il est temps que
le ministère de l'intérieur de façon
générale se réforme
cette affaire quelque part démontre
qu'il se passe des choses des
bizarreries qu'à m'en ont donné on a pu
on a dû laisser faire donc nous on a des
questionnements assez assez simple
d'abord parce que nos collègues ont été
profondément touché par cette affaire et
l'image que ça pouvait donner à
l'extérieur de l'institution policière
je rappelle qu effectivement de
commissaire hahn officiers ont fait
l'objet d'une suspension pour avoir
extrait en tout cas ce qu'ont lancé une
partie de la vidéo de la ville de paris
qui finalement ne fait que confirmer la
vidéo qui a été filmé par un citoyen le
1er mai à l'occasion de cette
manifestation et on devrait pas qu'on
déplace la problématique de fond sur
cette extraction d'une vidéo qui certes
est une faute mais qui n'est que une
extrapolation de la problématique de
faut donc nous les questions que nous
posons et qui quelque part créer une
frustration chez nos collègues de tous
grades et de tout corps sait comment
alors qu'on a un service de
professionnels recrutés sélectionné
composée d'officiers de l'officier de
gendarmerie de sites police de gardiens
de la paix de gendarmes le groupement de
sécurité de la présidence de la
république
pourquoi prendre un conseiller sécurité
qui est opérationnel sur le terrain
donc il doit pas y avoir de confusion
des genres au moment où on envisage dans
le cadre de
cannes 22 peut être recrutés sur des
postes comme cela de sécurité des
contractuels ça pose des questions de
fond sur le respect des règles
déontologiques qui sont je vous le
rappelle le principe de base de
l'ensemble des policiers qui sont
recrutés qui doivent s'y soumettre et
qui je vous le rappelle sont représente
70% des sanctions prononcées au sein de
la fonction publique
deuxième élément effectivement si ça
avait été un gardien de la paix qui
avait commis ces violences illégitimes
en dehors du cadre légal
évidemment qu'une procédure aurait été
immédiatement engagées d'un point de vue
administratif évidemment d'un point de
vue pénal sûrement donc deux poids deux
mesures pourquoi est ce que pour
monsieur benalla il n'y a pas eu c'est
toute l'histoire de l'article 40
effectivement immédiatement une saisine
des instances juridictionnelles
indépendante
troisième sujet comment on apprend qu
avons nous pu doter
cet agent à la base de sécurité privée
certes avec un poste prestigieux à
l'elysée d'un véhicule équipé police
avec des gyrophares intégrés dans les
pare-chocs tout neuf
alors qu'on a les fonctions de police
qui au quotidien roulent dans des
véhicules de plus de 200 mille
kilomètres en mauvais état pourquoi
avons-nous quelqu'un à doter monsieur
benalla d'un brassard police
je lui ai apporté ici qui est quand même
le symbole d'une fonction qu'on se doit
de respecter qui nous engage partie
romande intervient sur la voie publique
forcément c'est la police qu'on voit
c'est pas monsieur benalla donc c'est
toute l'image négative que ça a pu faire
rejaillir sur la police nationale et
comment as tu ponds avons nous pu nommer
monsieur benalla qui avait été
effectivement membre de la commission de
la réserve opérationnelle de la
gendarmerie et c'est tout à son honneur
nous on prône effectivement qu'une
réserve opérationnelle de ce type puisse
exister la police nationale parce que
c'est des citoyens qui donnent de leur
temps et c est ça serait tout à fait
légitime
comment at on pu nommer ce monsieur au
grade de lieutenant colonel
ça veut pas c'est pas insignifiant même
si certains disent que c'est honorifique
et qui plus est avec la qualité
d'experts expert en quoi
à 26 ans on experts de quoi dans le
domaine de la sécurité présidentielle
avec eux alors qu'on a des collègues qui
arrivent dans ces services là que ça
soit le service de la protection ou que
ça soit le service la protection du
président de la république c'est
plusieurs années pour acquérir
l'expérience et pouvoir être sélectionné
dans ces services là alors nous un peu
particulièrement sa noblesse d'autant
plus que pour le corps des officiers de
police ce que je représente
majoritairement on interdit aux
policiers qui sont commissaires
commandants comme ici commandant
divisionnaire pardon qui a été créée il
ya deux ans où leur de monsieur 15,9 de
porter ses galons parce qu'on nous en
estime indigne de vous comprenez que
sacré chez les officiers de police que
nous représentons certaine indignation
c'est à dire que honorifique mans on
peut porter ces gallois en tout cas s'en
prévaloir
mais nous par rapport l'exercice de nos
fonctions qu'on peut faire
au quotidien on n'aurait pas le droit de
les porter donc c'est tout un ensemble
de choses le chose qu'il faut que les
policiers sont interrogatifs et la
conclusion de tout ça c'est si on en
vient alors qu'on a deux cent cinquante
mille policiers et gendarmes dans ce
pays qui par rapport au ratio europe 1
et gamache et un chiffre un homme en
tout cas significatif
est-ce qu'on a un problème de confiance
vis-à-vis d'eux pourquoi aller chercher
des agents de sécurité privés pour
intégrer la sécurité du président de la
république
c'est une véritable question et nous
nous la posons au moment où on te dois
d'être transparent look nous en
conclusion avant que denis jacob
complète s'il le souhaite bien entendu
nous on demande sur cette question
peut-être symbolique en donnant des
réponses précises sur toutes les
questions matérielles que je viens
d'énumérer
et puis sur cette question du galop nage
en tout cas de cette réserve citoyenne
on demande qu'elle soit rendue publique
parce que quelque part ceux qui en font
partie
peut-être pour des raisons tout à fait
louables sont aussi sali par finalement
l' usage en tout cas le fait que
monsieur bénard puissent avorter donc
nous on demande transparence sur cette
liste de cette réserve citoyenne et de
cette réserve d'experts parce que des
experts par définition ou les rémunèrent
et je pense qu'on a suffisamment
d'experts auprès des tribunaux et au
sein des forces de police plutôt que
d'aller en chercher ailleurs sans plus
value forcément évident donc si on veut
être transparents et cette affaire
montre qu' elle l'opacité
nous on demande que cette clis de la
réserve citoyenne soit rendue publique
on sait très bien de qui elle est
composée may et une opacité depuis
plusieurs années sur cette question et
en a saisi la cada la haute autorité de
la transparence de la vie publique le
ministre de l'intérieur de l'époque
lorsque gendarmes ont intégré le
ministère de l'intérieur
la réponse a toujours été négatives
voilà monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs ce que je
souhaitais vous dire en propos liminaire
je vous remercie monsieur le secrétaire
général monsieur le secrétaire général
[Musique]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
alors je vais essayer d'être rapide
compte tenu que vous avez certainement
des questions à poser et pour pas être
trop redondant par rapport à ce qu'a pu
dire jean marc bailleul oui
contrairement à ce qu'on a pu lire ou
entendre là l'image de la police a été
salie qu'on le veuille ou qu'on ne
veuille pas là et et pourquoi parce que
avant que cette affaire n'éclate
il s'est écoulé deux mois et demi
pendant deux mois et demi ceux qui ont
eu un vécu cette affaire c'est une
bavure policière
avant même qu'on identifie monsieur
benalla comme n'étant pas policier donc
l'image de la police elle a été ternie
aujourd'hui les collègues notamment
gradés et gardiens sont particulièrement
mécontents en colère vous imaginez bien
pourquoi avec tous les événements qu'on
a connus au delà même des attentats mais
sur les différentes manifestations
particulièrement violentes
ils ont été mis en cause à plusieurs
reprises pointé du doigt et aujourd'hui
leur image qui a été sali par ce
comportement
ce que je veux à tes dires également
c'est que par rapport
je vais pas être redondant mais aussi
par rapport à l'intervention précédente
mais par rapport aux crs il faut savoir
effectivement que les crs sont une
mission celle du maintien de l'ordre et
qu'ils sont constitués en une unité très
déterminé qu'ils ne peuvent pas faire
autre chose que du maintien de l'ordre
ils ne sont pas là pour faire des
missions de sécurité publique sur des
manifestations et qui effectivement
quand il interpelle quelqu'un il le
passe derrière à d'autres services de
police qui prennent en charge et qui
gère donc ils doivent avant tout se
préoccuper de savoir si un mouvement de
personnes essayent de passer la limite
du cortège qui a été déterminé lors de
l'organisation de la manifestation soit
les repousser soit les empêcher de
passer il faut savoir qu'en matière de
maintien de l'ordre et d'une manière
générale en matière de missions de
police nationale la police s'adapte et
se remet en cause régulièrement
il faut savoir qu'en maintien de l'ordre
il ya actuellement une redéfinition de
la doctrine d'emploi des compagnies
républicaines de sécurité pour ce
qu'elles puissent agir et intervenir par
rapport aux
elle contrainte qu'elle vit sur le
terrain en matière notamment de
violences et ça c'est important de le
préciser également ensuite sur les
conditions de travail
le comportement de monsieur benalla bien
évidemment quand on le voit porter des
signes distinctifs de la police
nationale il n'y a pas de confusion
possible
il est policier dans l'esprit de la
population est effectivement se pose le
questionnement de comment différencier
ou pas les observateurs
je dirais que jusqu'à présent il n'y a
jamais eu de soucis que ce soit avec des
journalistes avec des chercheurs et des
sociologues qui ont pu faire appel aux
services de police pour pour être
présent en tant qu'observateur il nous a
jamais eu de signe distinctif c'est que
il ya une pratique qui est très stricte
ils sont encadrés ils sont ils ont des
moyens de protection qui ne sont pas
sérigraphié police et on se pose donc
légitimement la question de savoir
pourquoi monsieur benalla avait un
casque police avait un brassard police
et avait une radio police je ne
reviendrai pas sur l'histoire du
véhicule effectivement là aussi il ya un
profond mécontentement quand on voit une
personne je vais pas faire de publicité
pour une marque automobile en
particulier
mais monsieur benalla qui roulent en
talisman quand même pas un petit
véhicule de police équipées de tous les
moyens alors conseillé que nos collègues
au quotidien travaille avec des
véhicules qui peuvent avoir 200 ou 300
mille kilomètres au compteur
c'est juste pas concevable donc
effectivement cette affaire met en
lumière certaines pratiques mais des
pratiques qui ne sont pas des pratiques
de policiers parce qu'on parle de
policiers depuis des jours et des jours
je rappelle que ce sont pas des
policiers de terrain ce sont des haut
fonctionnaires des hautes personnalités
qui sont principalement aujourd'hui mise
en cause alors m'appartient pas de
porter de jugement là dessus il ya des
enquêtes en cours donc elles
détermineront les responsabilités des
uns des autres mais combien de fois on a
mis des policiers de terrain
en cause pointé du doigt et on n'a pas
attendu deux mois et demi pour qu'il
soit mis en garde à vue auditionné mis
en examen suspendu une enquête de l'igpn
une enquête judiciaire un déplacement de
services bref toutes les mesures
conservatoires qui sont prises dès qu'un
événement de ce type se produit donc je
rejoins ce que disait pour conclure jean
marc bailleul deux poids deux mesures je
vous remercie
merci mesdames messieurs quelqu'un
veut-il ajouter quelque chose dans notre
délégation mais on se fait paraphraser
un petit peu ce qu'a dit tout alors
monsieur bagel vous conviendrez avec moi
que la la sécurité du président de la
république revêt un caractère éminemment
régalien et au jour où des orientations
sont lancés visant à insérer des agents
contractuels ou de sécurité privées pour
assurer ses missions c'est mettre en
branle la sûreté de l'état et de ses
institutions aujourd'hui divers question
se pose alors comment ce monsieur
benalla qui voilà qui s'est lancé dans
des des aventures façon autocratique at
il pu s'accaparer un certain nombre de
missions à caractère régalien sans aucun
contrôle avait-il une fiche de poste une
feuille de mission c'est à mon sens une
question que de vrais oeufs et du cid et
ce commission je vous remercie madame
messieurs je tiens à vous apporter une
précision
ça n'est pas sans raison que la
commission des lois du sénat a choisi de
vous entendre avant toutes les
personnalités qui ont été convoqués pour
nous c'est une manière pour nous
d'assurer la police nationale mais aussi
la gendarmerie qui n'a pas
d'organisation syndicale bien sûr de
notre profond respect de notre profond
soutien et aussi de notre attention aux
conditions de la mise en oeuvre de ses
responsabilités de leurs
responsabilité je tiens a voulu dire et
à vous assurer que s'agissant de la
question des moyens de la police et de
la gendarmerie vous nous trouverez
toujours à vos côtés comme nous l'avons
été au cours des dernières années
je vais donner maintenant la parole à
nos deux rapporteurs madame jourdain
merci monsieur le président je m'associe
bien évidemment aux derniers propos du
président mais je pense que l'ensemble
de la commission s'y associent je
voulais vous poser une question sur le
statut d'observateur j'ai cru comprendre
que c'était un statut qui n'était guère
défini en revanche vous avez dit tout à
l'heure monsieur jacob
les observateurs sont normalement
encadré pouvez vous m'en dire plus sur
cet encadrement et sur le fait qu' il
est exister ou pas pour monsieur b
dallas par rapport à la connaissance que
vous avez vu alors je vais vous répondre
de manière générale puisque dans le cas
du traitement de monsieur benalla je ne
sais pas ce qui a été fait à ce jour
mais dans le traitement des observateurs
en général c'est une demande qui est
fait notamment et c'est la plus pratique
la plus courante
c'est des demandes de journalistes dans
le cadre de leur mission de reporter
sollicite une demande d'autorisation
auprès en général du cabinet du préfet
de police
s'agissant de la préfecture de police
demandant l'autorisation de pouvoir
accompagner tel ou tel service de police
dans le cadre d'un reportage qui portera
sur le tel sujet si ça relève d'une
direction spécifique la direction
spécifique et consulté on lui demande
son avis est ensuite allé en réponse et
il organise l'accompagnement d'un
observateur qui est mis sous la
responsabilité d'un agent de police en
général ça peut être un gradé ça peut
être un officier voir aussi un
commissaire de police est donc cette
personne qui devient référente de
l'observateur doit lui indiqué que l est
observateur et qu'elle ne peut pas
intervenir qu elle ne peut pas agir de
manière libre et qu'elle est soumise
donc aux règles de fonctionnement des
unités de police et elle n'a pas aller
et venir comme on le voit d'ailleurs sur
la vidéo avec monsieur benalla qui
arrive qui parle qui va dans tous les
sens non ce monsieur aurait dû rester
auprès de son référent et observer ce
qui se passait et ça s'arrête ça
s'arrête là donc il ya un cadre si ya
pas de statut
légal aujourd'hui d'observateurs il y à
un cadre de fonctionnement qui est quand
même défini sur la présence d'un
observateur dans des missions de police
et puisque on entendu dès le début de
cette affaire qu'il fallait prévoir un
statut éventuellement une tenue encore
un effort observateurs du jour créer des
choses nouvelles pour des épiphénomènes
certes ils font couler beaucoup d'encre
mais ça se passe toujours bien
c'est à dire que ce soit les
journalistes les magistrats ou les
parlementaires qui assiste à des
opérations de maintien de l'ordre de
personnes police n'y a pas de problème
de calandre ne pas créer encore des
usines à gaz qui va engendrer des frais
pour des exceptions et en l'occurrence
lèvera question que doivent se poser les
commissions c'est qui était le référent
de la préfecture de police pour monsieur
vénale à ce jour là alors je pense que
dans ma question vous avez la réponse
non je n'ai pas compris
forcément quelqu'un de la direction de
l'ens public de la préfecture de police
qui était à proximité c'est la règle il
faut maintenant trouver à quel niveau
situez cette responsabilité j'en profite
tout de suite pour dire puisque déjà
comme appareil de l'emploi des crs et je
sais que c'est aussi un nouveau
questionnement les crs sont dans une
mission soumis à une autorité à
l'autorité civile
donc à partir du moment où ils sont dans
leur mission en l'occurrence avec des
jets de projectiles ou vous avez vu tout
ça sur cette place s'il voit un policier
puisqu'ils l'ont vu comme policier agir
c'est pas à eux d'intervenir pour mettre
fin à ces agissements
c'est à l'autorité de ce policier en
civil non qu'en l'occurrence de ce faux
policiers monsieur ben alors qu'ils
auraient dû immédiatement intervenir en
lui disant vous êtes complètement dehors
des clous et vous mettez derrière en
observation parce qu'on peut pas être à
la fois en sécurisation en protection et
puis intervenir pour mettre fin aux
agissements d'un collègue d'un autre
service qui est censé en civil récupérer
les gens interpellés
j'en profite pour le dire j'aurais dû le
dire en propos liminaire puisque vous
avez parlé des moyens monsieur le
président c'est qu'on voulait souligner
l'excellence du rapport qui a été fait
par la commission sénatoriale sur les
moyens de la police
des forces de sécurité franchement il ya
beaucoup de questions justes et
légitimes et on est assez satisfait
d'avoir vu beaucoup de nos constats qui
ont été repris je le dis je dois
poursuivre dix là là aussi j'espère
qu'on en tirera des conséquences pour
être beaucoup plus rationnel est
beaucoup plus efficace
je vous remercie monsieur le président
sur wii merci monsieur le président ma
question est très simple qu'elle était
quelle était la qualité des relations de
vos collègues de la police nationale
avec monsieur benalla premier point
deuxièmement comme théoriquement si j'ai
bien compris il n'avait pas de raison de
donner des ordres ou de faire des
injonctions à des agents de la police
nationale ou de la gendarmerie nationale
est il arrivé que certains manifestent
le refus d'obéir et troisièmement ne
vous paraît-il pas en conséquence
opportun que l'on puisse réfléchir à ce
qu'il n'y ait que des fonctionnaires de
la gendarmerie nationale et de la police
nationale pour assumer les missions de
sécurité du président de la république
et des ministres par exemple bien
monsieur by lg j'ai commencé par la
dernière question puisqu'on y a répondu
par l'intervention de tout à l'heure
bien entendu c'est une mission
régalienne pour lesquelles les agents
sont formés sélectionnés et doivent
rendre compte lors de leurs agissements
conforme aux règles déontologiques qui
s'applique aux policiers nationaux
deuxième question refus d'obéir je crois
j'ai lu la presse comme vous tous que
c'est arrivé s'il n'y a pas si longtemps
que ça à l'aéroport de roissy où il
semblerait que monsieur bénard a évolué
s'immiscer dans l'organisation du départ
des joueurs de l'équipe de france et
qu'un officier de gendarmerie lui a dit
a rappelé que c'était lui le chef et qu'
il n'avait pas à recevoir d'ordres de
monsieur n'à si je pense que ce genre
d'armes pour être facilement retrouver
et pourra
le confirmer après les relations en tout
cas on en a eu des remontées
c'est à dire que nous on a eu les
remonter et pas simplement d'agents de
police c'est qui semblerait que monsieur
benalla interférait intervenait y
compris quand il y avait des hauts
responsables de la police nationale et
c'est ça qui est d'autant plus gênant
est la question que nous on se pose
c'est si tel a été le cas où s dlp au
gspr ou ailleurs à l'occasion
d'organisation de voyages présidentiels
y compris en province y at-il eu des
remontées auprès des autorités
supérieures de 800 l'intérieur pour
dénoncer ce comportement qui indigne
imaginons linverse qu'un agent de police
viennent contredire les ordres de son
supérieur je peux vous dire ça durera
pas deux minutes
donc elle encore deux poids deux mesures
merci beaucoup
nous sommes pris un peu par le temps sur
si vous aviez une précision qui n'a pas
été annoncée
alors mes chers collègues je sais que
vous avez à coeur de rivaliser de
concision dans vos questions j'ai pu le
constater tout à l'heure je donne la
parole à monsieur collombat merci
monsieur le président après m associé à
ce que vous avez vos propos vous avez
tenus sur confiance que nous avons dans
nos forces de l'ordre ce qui dans cette
affaire par beaucoup de choses méthode
n'est ce qui m'étonne peut-être le plus
c'est que monsieur benalla soit au
ministère de l'intérieur et aux abords
comme un poisson dans l'eau
dire que on ne sait pas qui il est
vraiment mais on l'équipe on le laisse
participer voire s'imposer à des
opérations de maintien de l'ordre
il participe régulièrement apparemment
d'après ce que dit la presse à des
débriefings bon avec pour seul laissez
passer
le fait qu'ils soient du cabinet du
président de la république fera jusqu'à
présent je croyais mais je peux être que
je me trompe que le chef de la police
c'était le mini de la gendarmerie
c'était le ministre de l'intérieur
s'était pas le président de la
république et qui avait même un premier
ministre était le chef d
fatigué collègues qui compte pensez donc
voilà donc est-ce que ce que vous
trouvez pas ça ça à étonnants et comment
se fait-il que ne soit jamais rien passé
alors que bon il y avait quand même des
gens qui savaient que c'était pas normal
très bien je vous remercie madame cost
merci monsieur le président la présence
d'observateurs extérieurs dans les
manifestations et elle fréquente
si oui je voudrais savoir quand les
forces de police ou de gendarmerie sont
elles prévenu de la présence de ces
observateurs je vous remercie madame
benbassa merci monsieur le président ma
question et pour monsieur bayonne lors
de votre émission sur bfm rmc
vous avez parlé des échos que vous
auriez eu c'est pas très claire des
échos que vous auriez eu sur la
participation de monsieur benalla à des
réunions pendant qu'il était mis à pied
est ce que voulaient confirmer où vous
les incriminés
je ne fasse je n'ai pas très bien
compris lorsque vous avez parlé lors de
cette émission merci je vous remercie
madame benbassa monsieur fichiers oui
merci monsieur le président la première
question concerne des galons que vous
avez arboré tout à l'heure de lieutenant
colonel
est ce à dire que ce monsieur donc
mettez un costume du temps collé avec
des galons et pouvait être en prévaloir
dans des cérémonies
et puis comment circule ces observateurs
parce que on comprend bien qu'il ya une
règle et à côté de ça ce que l'on
constate nous c'est que les observateurs
parce que monsieur benalla circuler
partout y accéder à des réunions
stratégiques où semble-t-il personne ne
lui demandait de compte il lui suffisait
de dire qu'il représentait de cabinet du
président de la république pour que i
les portes ouvertes et accès à toutes
les informations
merci cher collègue monsieur kerrouche
ont une question extrêmement courte
qu'elles sont habituellement les
équipements qui sont données à un
observateur merci monsieur kerrouche
monsieur grosdidier
oui d'abord je vous remercie pour
l'hommage que vous a rendu à notre
rapport effectivement nous identifions
un certain nombre d'aidés causes du
malaise et parmi ces très nombreuses
causes
il y avait l'organisation en tuyaux
d'orgue il y avait le un manque de
transparence souvent dans l'ensemble des
procédures et comme des processus de
commandement et illies alpes et aussi le
fait simplement
contrairement à la gendarmerie la police
ne soit pas dirigé par des policiers et
alors que quand vous poser le problème
des observateurs est ce que c'est le
problème des observateurs clairement
identifié comme observateur ou parfois
de fonctionnaires d'autorité qui qui
sont pas nécessairement policiers et
dans chaque département on sait que des
membres du corps préfectoral sont amenés
à tam n'a dirigé par action de police
après ce qu il ya des gens qui ont un
statut moins évident et est-ce qu'il
s'est créé une mauvaise habitude de
d'ordre direct ou de respect des ordres
directs ne passant pas forcément par par
la hiérarchie policière
est-ce qu'on est là dans la sphère la
plus emblématique mais d'un problème qui
est plus général et est ce qu'il y à
dire une doctrine très claire en la
matière merci cher collègue madame
delattre merci président que vous
parliez tout à l'heure
d'image extrait de la vidéo protection
de paris nous savons qu'il y à aussi une
vidéo amateur d'un manifestant qui était
présent ou en tout cas de quelqu'un qui
assistent et nous pensons qu
effectivement la compagnie de crs était
vidéosurveillées avez vous connaissance
d'une vidéo de cette vidéo des crs nous
n'en avons pas entendu parler pensez
vous qu'elle sera effectivement dans l'
enquête judiciaire
merci madame delattre également de votre
concision madame lherbier
messieurs ce qui m'a étonné c'est
concernant la réserve citoyenne
il semblerait d'après ce que vous dites
que ce soit non transparent moi j'en
fais partie on m'a demandé des tas de
trucs jusqu'aux contrats de mariage qui
était le mien et je vais demander qui a
ses renseignements alors si c'est pas
ouvert à tous merci madame lherbier vous
avez quelques minutes madame messieurs
pour nous répondre
il faut que vous rapprochiez le micro
parce qu'on a un système
voilà merci qui n'est pas très puissant
concernant la réserve citoyenne vous
avez sans doute rempli des documents et
pour nous ça nous pose problème pourquoi
l'occasion de cette affaire d'ailleurs
beaucoup de gens découvrent ce que c'est
vous avez une réserve opérationnelle qui
est trente mille personnes qui
travaillent au quotidien pour la
sécurité dans des patrouilles qui
passent des grades qui font des
formations et c'est très intéressant il
faudrait qu'ils aient une réserve
opérationnelle pour toute la police
nationale et la gendarmerie qui soient
uniques concernant la réserve citoyenne
aujourd'hui en france nous avons une
réserve citoyenne pour toutes les armes
et à la gendarmerie nationale représente
la moitié de ses ravisseurs un service
citoyen qui sont nommées en raison de
l'heure ainsi que sept sénateurs députés
dans plein de raisons il ya 1500
officiers qui sont nommés par la
gendarmerie
pratiquement que des officiers colonel
et lieutenant colonel je crois que le
président du sénat d'ailleurs les en
toute transparence
mais ce qui me pose problème c'est qu'on
a demandé à toutes les autorités que ces
personnes là beaucoup de journalistes
soit identifié c'est à dire que vous
faites des papiers mais personne ne le
sait or cette réserve citoyenne elle est
fait pour rapprocher larmes des citoyens
et nous nous pensons que c'est une noble
cause mais que par contre elle doit être
transparente puisque vous avez du
travail en commission vous avez des élus
il ne peut pas y avoir de conflit
d'intérêts ni des journalistes nous
avons posé la question à tous les
présidents du sénat de l'assemblée
ministre de l'intérieur président d'art
public cada haute autorité de la
transparence personne n'a voulu le faire
pour quelles raisons combien yat-il
d'alexandre benalla sur cette réserve
citoyenne parce qu'il ya des gens qui
occupent des responsabilités qui
favorisent ce rapprochement
mais comme y at-il de personnes comme ça
pour quelles raisons la question qui se
pose dans cette affaire ensuite c'est
qu'on a découvert qu'il y avait des
experts 74e' la gendarmerie nationale
mais qu'en est il at il été nommé
monsieur alexandre ménard à quelle date
pour quelles missions pour combien de
temps et est il rémunéré
toutes ces questions il faut répondre
est-ce que c'est uniquement parce que
monsieur pénale a été président en
europe de la république que on avait un
intérêt à voir quelqu'un qui est dans le
sérail peut-être pour les évolutions du
justement de l'organisation de la
sécurité du président toutes ces
questions il va falloir répondre mais
nous demandons il veut remercier la
transparence mais je vois très bien nous
sommes obligés d'accélérer un petit peu
le rythme parce que nous sommes
bousculés par le temps et donc il
faudrait que vous puissiez répondre mais
aussi concise mans que nos collègues
sénateurs ont posé leurs questions sur
les différents points qui ont été
soulevées alors pure en sont partis sans
les réponses que jacob répandra sur tout
ce qui est statut d'observateur moi je
vais essayer de répondre aux autres que
j'ai pris à la volée alors est ce qu on
a connaissance d'agents qui ont refusé
d'obéir je crois que j'ai répondu tout à
l'heure
très clairement sur le poisson dans
l'eau oui c'est à dire qu'effectivement
manifestement il est un peu ce qu'ils
voulaient quand on a appris qu'il avait
un badge d'accès à l'assemblée nationale
c'est qu'on apprendra qu'il avait pour
le sénat je sais pas
je vous rassure je vous rassure que
quand on vient à l'assemblée nationale
ou à l'assemblée nationale que nous
sommes armés
nous on est obligé de passer par tout un
tas de procédures semblerait que si
monsieur benalla était armé lui ça doit
être plus simple pour lui
donc là encore deux pas de mesure ça
veut dire qu'en fait on lui donnait
toutes les accréditations
sans parler de sa carte de visite où il
a marqué adjoint du chef du cabinet
l'elysée ça ouvre beaucoup de portes
il faut vous mettre à la place de tout
un tas de policiers qui quelque part se
disent qu'est ce qu'il va se passer pour
moi si j'arrête je viens me mettre à
l'encontre de ce monsieur dont on ne
connaît pas forcément la capacité de
nuisance eurent ensuite la question sur
le débriefing bah oui je nous on est
syndicaliste j'aurais bien aimé un jour
assister un débriefing grande
manifestation à préfecture de police on
nous a dit que c'était une quarantaine
de personnes j'ose espérer quand même
que tout le monde peut pas rentrer là
dedans comme dans un moulin il
semblerait qu' il a pu assister au
débriefing du premier mail ça pose des
questions et pour répondre à madame ben
benzema 5-0 là j'ai pas faire la
confusion dans ce matin moi je vais être
très claire nous on a eu des remontées
je réponds à une question pareille
occasion de collègues qui nous ont dit
qu'ils se comportaient un petit peu
comme un cador pourquoi ils tous
devaient lui est ouvert et qui reprenait
les gens et qu'ils intervenaient sur les
dispositifs ça veut bien dire qu'il
pensait capable de tout faire moi ce
matin j'ai répondu cela et que
effectivement il a été vu sur plusieurs
opérations et sur plusieurs des
briefings sur les faux voyages
présidentiels
et moi je me suis basé sur mon interview
de ce matin sur le des garçons de
monsieur gilles a c'est à dire que quand
monsieur gibelin dis moi j'ai tendance à
croire ce que j'entends quand quelqu'un
jure devant une assemblée que il l'a vu
agir devant dans cette période du cateau
en 19 mai si je ne m'abuse
j'ai répondu à la question que les gens
et même à le poser en off avant et j'ai
dis qu'effectivement il avait été vu
puisque monsieur gibelin qui peut le
plus peut le moins
il a démenti ces propos je ne peux pas
assumer
les propos que monsieur gibelin a tenu
donc voilà donc c'est exactement dans ce
contexte là que j'ai répondu en tout cas
il a été vu et ce que je note c'est
qu'il a été surtout vu et ça partout les
policiers au pied du bus à roissy et les
champs elysées l'équipe de france et que
quand on est rendus sur les tâches
administratives mois en général quand on
est sur des tâches administratives en
est au bureau on est passé à voie
publique mais vous répondra à la
question concernant concernant est ce
que les agents sur le terrain sont
prévues de la présence d'observateurs
non tout simplement parce qu'un
observateur il est sous la
responsabilité d'un référent qu'il n'a
pas de rôle actif sur des missions de
police qui doit être en retrait que par
conséquent nos collègues n'ont pas
forcément être informés qu'un
observateur à proximité puisque il n'a
pas lieu qu'il soit en contact direct et
en intervention directe avec les
collègues sur sur le terrain s'agissant
des équipements ce sont des équipements
effectivement de protection qui peuvent
être données
cyril est accompagnateur sur des
missions à risque mais jamais en tous
les cas pas à ma connaissance on a eu
une information que ses observateurs et
équipés de matériel police alors par
exemple si on donne un gilet pare balles
le gilet pare-balles le mot police et un
scratch qui a dessus donc il suffit de
l'enlever pour le rendre le rendre
civile donc il n'y a pas de difficultés
là il avait un casque si les polices bon
là aussi il faut s'interroger sur qui a
pu donner ce matériel de police
concernant les vidéos amateurs et
potentiellement la vidéo du de la crs
alors il faut savoir qu'effectivement
les crs sont équipés de moyens mobiles
vidéo mais qu' ils en ont pas en nombre
suffisant pour couvrir tous les points
d'implantation qu'ils ont dans le cadre
de leur mission et que peut-être que sur
ce lieu là il n'y avait pas une
en tous les cas on en n'a pas
connaissance à ce jour mais sur la place
juppé comment elle s'appelle l'a
peut-être que peut-être que lui
peut-être que la contrescarpe peut-être
que l'unité en question n'avaient pas de
moyens mobiles vidéo ceci étant il y
avait la vidéo de la ville de paris qui
a suffisamment couverts les faits et
c'est d'ailleurs cette vidéo qui a été
extraite je crois est donnée semble-t-il
à monsieur benalla qui est là pour de
toute façon de témoigner de ce qui s'est
passé
voilà j'ai essayé de faire vite je pense
que je répondu à peu près merci beaucoup
monsieur jacob monsieur by elle demande
la parole pour une si petite
présentation technique sur la vidéo donc
effectivement il n'y avait que deux
sections de la compagnie sur cette place
donc la vidéo est utilisé que lorsque la
compagnie et en unités constituées c'est
à dire face aux manifestants en ordre
serré et on filme ce qui se fait en face
et derrière les crs pour voir quels
visages de leurs armes ils font et c'est
donc quand les compagnies comme l'a dit
denis jacob sont éclatés les sections
sont éclatés la vidéo elle peut pas se
démultiplier donc ça peut expliquer qu
effectivement il n'y avait pas forcément
de vidéos sur cette place là mais ça a
été dit il ya suffisamment d'image sans
besoin d'en rajouter je crois qu'elles
sont suffisamment explicites
madame messieurs je vous remercie
beaucoup de votre excellente coopération
avec la commission des lois et nous
allons reprendre maintenant la
délégation suivante
bien mes chers collègues nous
auditionnons maintenant la délégation de
la fédération unsa que préside monsieur
philippe capon en qualité de secrétaire
général et je vais maintenant vous prie
de vous asseoir vous demander de bien
vouloir prêter serment
c'est une obligation qu'il faut
respecter
quand une commission permanente exerce
les pouvoirs d'une commission denquête
je rappelle qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission des lois doté de ses
pouvoirs serait passible de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
damende je vous invite messieurs a prêté
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité levé la main droite et dit je
le jure j'ai bien entendu je vous
remercie vous avez la parole pour
quelques minutes
il faut que vous ne le laisse il nous
laissait ensuite le temps que les
rapporteurs vous pose des questions
auxquelles vous répondrais et que mes
collègues sénateurs qui le souhaiteront
vous pose aussi des questions et nous
n'avons plus que un peu plus de vingt
minutes pour vous entendre donc c'est
dire que c'est un exercice de concision
et je demande à mes collègues de bien
vouloir vous écouté avec attention sans
qu'il y ait de conversations
particulière ce sera beaucoup plus
efficace pour travailler s'il vous plaît
mais là monsieur monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs
je commencerai à une intervention par un
propos liminaire
je vous remercie de nous avoir convoqué
devant la commission des lois sur les
conditions dans lesquelles des personnes
n'appartenant pas aux forces de sécurité
ont pu ou peuvent être associés à
l'exercice dans leur mission de maintien
de l'ordre et de protection des hautes
personnalités le régime de sanctions
applicables en cas de manquement la
fédération unsa face me représente
l'ensemble des corps et des métiers de
la police nationale les policiers
effectuent un travail compliqué
engageant soumis à des horaires
atypiques complètement aux
réglementations européennes
par exemple les crs présents ce jour sur
la place de la contrescarpe ont effectué
une vacation de 16h30 en continu pour un
salaire de début de carrière d'à peine
1800 euros
pour un gardien de la paix le métier
dangereux les policiers comptent près de
5000 blessés en opération dans l'eau
rend chaque année travaillent parfois
dans des bâtiments délabrés sont très
contrôlés et très souvent sanctionnés
dans leur mission
depuis 2015 des policiers sont la cible
de nombreuses attaques terroristes ce
qui renforce le fait qu'ils sont très
vulnérables y compris dans leur vie
privée
ce sentiment est une réalité à tel point
que depuis ces derniers mois
le recrutement de policiers est devenu
complexe les candidats sont plus rares
et le ministère de l'intérieur a dû
lancer une campagne de recrutement pour
un coût de près d'un million d'euros
mais tout cela nous a pas échappé
puisque messieurs les sénateurs
grosdidier boutons ont effectué un
travail remarquable intitulé vaincre le
malaise des forces de sécurité
intérieure une exigence républicaine
merci qui confirme mon propos et le
malaise parmi les forces de l'ordre
touchée par un mal devenu profond quel
est le sens donné aujourd'hui au métier
de policier syndicaliste policier j'ai
effectué ma carrière en crs maison que
je connais bien j'ai en ma qualité de
syndicaliste était très récemment
auditeurs 2017-2018 de ligne j 29e 29ème
session baptisée colonel beltrame
le groupe de travail auquel j'ai
participé ali naji a porté sur la
gestion démocratique des foules
cette précision me permet aujourd'hui de
confirmer que le dispositif permettant à
l'énergie d'envoyer des observateurs
dans les services de police a été
régulièrement mises en place en
particulier sur le ressort de la
préfecture de police est en moi même
policiers je n'ai pas participé
directement à ces immersions mais les
auditeurs de mon groupe qui ont
participé m'ont fait part des modalités
de cette qualité d'observateurs cette
qualité d'observateur et temporaires
limité à un temps déterminé les
matériels mis à disposition de
l'observateur le son comme au mans et
sur le temps passé dans le service
d'immersion en cette qualité
d'observateurs un exemple d'une
immersion
ambac nuit 94 dépendant de la direction
de la sécurité de proximité de
l'agglomération parisienne une des
directions de la pp
là des strates le commissaire de service
m'a contactée dans l'après midi afin de
savoir si je venais apparemment il avait
un document officiel de la préfecture de
police avec mon nom et les coordonnées à
lors de la prise de fonction le
commissaire commandant la bac nuit 94
m'a reçu petit briefing notamment
sécurité puis remise du gilet pare
balles pour lui l'important était ma
sécurité donc pas d'intervention et
attendre l'ordre de l'équipage pour
sortir du véhicule
une fois avec l'équipage celui-ci
veiller à ce que la situation soit
claire afin de m'autoriser à sortir du
véhicule
je n'ai pas eu de brassards police ni de
radio
pour moi ces propos que je ne voulais à
l'instant ce sont le retour d'un
observateur stagiaires de ligne j une
des directions de la pp
la death pape a donc très clairement
encadrait la présence des observateurs
dans ses missions non celle des bacs
particulièrement exposées dans leur
travail quotidien
concernant les dispositifs policiers sur
le terrain au maintien de l'ordre sur
paris les services de police sont
multiples sur le terrain ce qui peut
parfois engendrer certaines confusions
le maintien de l'ordre désiré par là des
opc de la préfecture de police une
compagnie de crs à son commandement
hiérarchique propre et prend saison de
prêt d'un commissaire lui même sur le
terrain appelé tei techniciens
d'intervention peuvent aussi intervenir
sur le terrain aux côtés des crs des
collègues ont tenu des compagnies
d'intervention de la démo pc mais
également des policiers des compagnies
de sécurisation et des bacs dépendant de
la death pape mais aussi les
fonctionnaires de la police scientifique
représenté aujourd'hui par benjamin
gayraud secrétaire général du snp ps
concernant l'organisation d'un maintien
de l'ordre à paris et plus
particulièrement sur le terrain les
policiers intervenant sera maintenu a
même mieux sont donc multiples et ne se
connaissent pas forcément
ce constat connu à d'ailleurs été fait
par le groupe de travail de l'énergie
dont je faisais partie puisque nous en
avons établi une recommandation dans nos
travaux recommandation numéro 9
clarifier en doctrine les missions
susceptibles d'échouer aux différents
types d'unités engagés
unité territoriale et forces mobiles
place et rôle de chacun dans la gestion
directe et l'émission encadrante pour
revenus pour revenir brièvement sur le
1er mai sur l'intervention de monsieur
benalla au cours de la manifestation
la qualité d'observateur n'était pas
connue des collègues crs sur le terrain
qu'ils pensaient avoir affaire à un
groupe de policiers en civil dont
faisait partie monsieur benalla en
qualité d'observateur au moment où les
crs ont remis la personne interpellée
aux personnes se trouvant juste derrière
eux qu'ils pensaient être des policiers
je parle donc de la première
intervention puisqu'il ya eu deux
interpellations ces deux personnes dont
monsieur benalla aurait dû pour moi
refusé de la prendre en compte est
décliné à ce moment là sa qualité
d'observateur et refuser de prendre en
charge cette personne puisqu'il était là
en qualité d'observateurs chose qui n'a
pas été fait
bien au contraire de ceux sur le terrain
recueillies auprès de mon délégué unsa
police
les collègues crs présents sur place
n'ont jamais été débordés à ce moment
précis de la manifestation je tiens à le
préciser lors de cette manifestation
monsieur benalla a été davantage perçu
comme un agitateur comme que comme un
observateur courant partout avec en tout
comportement qui aurait pu encore
davantage faire dégénérer à une
situation déjà bien entendu pour nous
cette affaire est grave non seulement
dans les faits mais cet aspect sera
traitée par les services concernés par
la justice
elle est grave car elle est révélatrice
d'un mode de fonctionnement inacceptable
au sein de notre institution qui jette
le discrédit sur les policiers la police
nationale et plus largement sur
l'ensemble des forces de sécurité
malheureusement cela est révélateur du
fonctionnement du ministère de
l'intérieur qui sur des sujets
importants aussi parfois entre la
politique de l'autruche et la partie de
ping pong envoya un d'autres la
responsabilité de décisions majeures
merci de m'avoir écouté je vous remercie
monsieur qu'est ce que l'un d'entre vous
souhaitent prendre la parole également
ce n'est pas le cas je vais donner alors
la parole à monsieur
rapporteur puis merci à eux merci
monsieur le kata général messieurs je
voulais d'abord redire combien nous
savons de considération pour les
fonctionnaires de la police nationale
que vous représentez ici avec vos
collègues des différentes organisations
nous savons que votre métier est dur et
nous savons la confiance qui doit vous
être apportées et raison de plus pour
que les choses soient précises
lorsqu il y à des situations qui sont
malsaines qui sont dommageables à cet
égard j'opposerai seulement trois
questions simples qu'elles étaient quel
est votre connaissance sur les relations
qu'ont eu vos collègues avec monsieur
benalla deuxièmement y at il des cas ou
compte tenu du fait que théoriquement
vos collègues y compris bien sûr ceux du
gspr ne sont pas sous l'autorité
hiérarchique d'une personne qui ne fait
pas partie de la police nationale ni de
la gendarmerie nationale y at il des cas
où il y a eu des disputes des
malentendus ou plutôt des refus de céder
à certaines injonctions ou certaines
commandes et enfin ne pensez vous pas
qu'il serait utile que peut-être la loi
précise à l'avenir qu'il revient à des
personnels de la police nationale et de
la gendarmerie nationale à l'exclusion
de tout autre de veiller à la sécurité
du président de la république et des
autres personnalités le haut niveau de
l'état
monsieur le secrétaire général sur le
président monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
je vais essayer de répondre précisément
aux trois points et rapidement les
relations des policiers que monsieur
benalla doivent être précisées en ce qui
concerne les cadres de la préfecture de
police
il ne pouvait pas pour la plupart de
ceux à qui j'ai discuté ne pas connaître
monsieur benalla puisqu'il était présent
dans le paysage policiers de la
préfecture de police de façon récurrente
je me suis exprimé là dessus
rapidement on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui que
c'est une réalité il venait très souvent
sur des services d'ordre aussi bien pour
des préparations que pour des
débriefings c'est tout à fait différent
comme l'a dit monsieur capon pour les
crs qui sont les compagnies qui viennent
à l'occasion de services ou de maintien
de l'ordre et qui repartent et qui
effectivement ne pouvait pas identifier
monsieur benalla il faut préciser aussi
que les cadres de la préfecture de
police connaissait monsieur benalla
comme étant une autorité
en tout cas il a été installé dans le
paysage comme tel et quand vous avez
tout commissaire que vous êtes une
autorité qui est celle instituée ou en
tout cas même si elle est autoproclamé
c'est comme ça qu'elle est acceptée
c'est le conseiller du président de la
république il n'y a pas de cadre au
niveau de ceux qui sont actuellement
mises en cause qui peuvent s'opposer à
cette présence si cette présence est
considéré comme validé au plus haut
niveau
ce que l'anc est j'espère démontrera
voilà pour les relations avec monsieur
benalla je n'irai pas plus loin puisque
le reste devait pas concerner l'enquète
et si certains policiers ont fauté dans
leurs relations avec monsieur benalla
ils en assumeront les conséquences comme
tous ceux qui sont aujourd'hui en train
de s'expliquer vis-à-vis la justice et
de votre commission pour des quatre
conflits
ça a été cité devant votre commission il
y en a eu un tout récent c'est celui du
retour du car de l'équipe de france où
monsieur benalla s'est permis de
s'immiscer dans un dispositif de façon
autoritaire et déplacés il ya eu un
conflit avec les autorités à roissy avec
les gendarmes également avec les
policiers de la police aux frontières
qui m'ont fait part et je crois même
pouvoir dire que c'est peut-être la
goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase
dans la façon de monsieur benhaddad se
comportaient qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
nous avons des révélations parce
qu'avant je reviens à la question
précédente personne ne parlait parce que
personne n'osait s'opposer à une
personnalité institutionnalisée comme
tel dans le paysage et pour le troisième
point bien évidemment là je me permets
de parler au nom de la fédération d'ong
policiers républicains
il est bien évident qu'il faut pour le
président de la république en
particulier pour les autorités de l'état
que ce soit des fonctionnaires de police
ou de gendarmerie qui puisse exercer ses
missions régaliennes et les plus
importantes qui consiste à protéger nos
chefs
merci monsieur madame jourdain merci
monsieur le président merci messieurs de
votre présence et je m'associe bien
évidemment propos de monsieur sur sur le
tout l'intérêt que nous portons et la
considération mes potes en force de
police et de gendarmerie
j'ai une question par rapport à vos
déclarations vous avez fait état du fait
que la qualité observateurs de monsieur
benalla n'était pas connue des crs qui
pensaient qu'il s'agissait d'un policier
en civil ça ce sont donc des
informations qui vous ont été remontées
du terrain par ailleurs pouvez vous nous
le confirmer mais pouvez-vous également
me dire si vous avez eu des informations
sur la façon dont ils étaient encadrés
en tant qu'observateur le secrétaire
général merci sur la sur la partie crs
nous avons effectivement pris contact et
que ne représentant unsa police dans la
crs concernés qu'ils ont confirmé qu' à
aucun moment les policiers les crs
présents sur place n'avait identifié
monsieur benalla comme étant un
observateur système avait été le cas
jamais il ne lui remis la personne
interpellée dons qu'ils ignoraient la
qualité il est pris pour un policier il
était en fait grimer comme un policier
pouvait laisser penser qu'il était
membre des forces de l'ordre
on est dans un contexte particulier
d'une manifestation les choses vont très
vite avec des mouvements de foule qui
sont peuvent être très rapides ce qui
explique cette cette situation sur cette
partie là je précise j'en profite
d'avoir la parole pour préciser aussi
que un certain nombre de moyens vidéos
et photos ont été effectuées par les crs
qu'il appartiendra naturellement à
lenquête et je n'ai pas de révélations à
faire là dessus de disposer de ces
éléments vidéos et photos concernant
cette manifestation particulière
alors madame jour d'amoureux madame je
voudrais appuyé sur votre micro si vous
voulez entendre votre question à l'est
en réalité c'est toujours la même c'est
avez vous des informations sur
l'encadrement éventuelle par un référent
de monsieur bernard le référent
semble-t-il devait y avoir un référent
puisqu'on était quand même sur une
équipe qui était présente sur le terrain
les crs n'avaient pas connaissance ce
jour là il s'avérait d'après les
éléments qui ont été connus et un
certain nombre de réponses car majeur de
la démo pc étaient présents ainsi qu'un
réserviste de la gendarmerie nationale
il semble que c'était l'équipe
le trio qui composaient l'équipe dont
monsieur mennella faisait partie ce jour
là merci de cette précision
mes chers collègues j'ai plusieurs
d'entre vous qui demande la parole je
rappelle la règle du jeu que nous avons
accepté ensemble des questions concise
pas plus d'une minute et si possible
beaucoup moins monsieur hervé
merci monsieur le président messieurs
chers collègues 1 ou sur un terrain moi
je rejoins totalement la description
vous avez fait de l'accueil des
stagiaires de l'énergie dans les rangs
de la police nationale à l'immersion je
les fais moins d'une heure avant de
devenir sénateur
à la 75ème comme la gendarmerie de
seine-et-marne ça s'est extrêmement bien
passé je peux vous assurez vous avez
très peu de barbe de marge de manoeuvre
vous êtes très bien encadré et entouré
par les fonctionnaires de police comme
par les mythes à la gendarmerie et qu'il
n'y a aucune possibilité aucune de
prêter main forte à vos services
d'ailleurs on n'est pas là pour ça je
pense qu'il s'applique dans cette
affaire-là et c'était à faire en
particulier au cas d'espèce une forme de
théories de l'apparence et monsieur ben
à la coche toutes les cases de la
théorie de l'apparence habilitation
secret défense permis de port d'armes
visiblement une capacité à nager comme
un poisson dans l'eau au sein des
services de la présidente de police
et puis un grade de lieutenant-colonel
de la réserve spécialisés qui a été
opérationnelle puis devenu citoyen dans
la marine je vous assure que les
questions la réserve spécialisés se pose
et je voulais surtout précisément sur
cette question là à voir votre approche
en tant que policier en représentant
un syndicat de police sur cette question
de la réserve citoyenne de la
gendarmerie nationale et quelle est
votre opinion sur cette question merci
beaucoup chers collègues et madame de la
gontrie
merci monsieur le président messieurs
auriez vous eu connaissance par vos
collègues de la présence de monsieur
benalla dans des circonstances analogues
pas forcément avec les mêmes
comportements dans le cadre d'autres
manifestations ma question est suscitée
par un certain nombre de photos ou de
vidéos qui circulent et dont on ne sait
pas très exactement qu'elle est là
comment dire la véracité ou la réalité
merci de votre question chère collègue
monsieur collombat je voulais simplement
il ya dans sa déclaration dans la
commission denquête le préfet de police
rappelé qu'il s'agissait de dérives
individuelles ce qui s'était passé bon
d'accord mais le tout sur fond de
copinage malsain entre un collaborateur
elysées et plusieurs fonctionnaires de
police ce qui est un petit peu c'est pas
fait prophète paulissen qu'il dit ça je
cite c'est un petit peu étonnant qu est
ce que vous pensez de cette déclaration
merci monsieur que l'on bat de votre
question qui est très précise et vous
pourrez d'ailleurs la reposer au préfet
de police
madame lherbier oui monsieur le
président tout à l'heure monsieur cap on
vous avait parlé vous avez dit il n'y a
pas eu de débordement à ce moment là
alors je voudrais savoir existe-t-il
parce que d'autres ont dit qu'ils
avaient eu débordements notamment
monsieur benhamadi
non mais eux ou s'il vous plaît je
voudrais savoir s'il existe une
procédure pour identifier ce qu'est un
débordement
est ce qu'un appel à l'aide je vais dire
de gens sur le terrain qui ont besoin de
renfort quand il ya débordement
merci madame l'habiller monsieur à la
marque merci présidente à la lorsqu'on
visionne les diverses images des
événements de la contrescarpe j'aimerais
avoir le sentiment de nos policiers qui
sont ici les policiers les crs
paraissent relativement calme maîtrise
de la situation et monsieur benalla
semble quelqu'un de particulièrement
agitée et j'aimerais savoir quelle est
leur sentiment
ce qu'ils pensent même s'ils ne sont pas
médecins et psychiatres de ce
comportement psychologique pour le monde
étrange où on a quelqu'un qui part dans
tous les sens qui est cela m'interpelle
quelque part quand on dirait j'aimerais
ça avoir votre sentiment là-dessus
merci cher collègue madame delattre et
président vous confirmez donc qu'il ya
eu des vidéos et des photos qui ont été
prises par les crs
elles n'ont pas été dévoilés donc je
pense qu'elles seront dans l' enquête
judiciaire elles seront versés dans
lequel judiciaire vous parlez d'un trio
moi je effectivement est ce que vous
confirmez est-ce que vous pouvez nous
redonner les nombres de ce trio de ce
commando benalla puisque visiblement il
n'avait pas de statut d'observateur mais
c'était un commando freelance
pensez vous qu'il y avait d'autres
membres de ce commando
madame benbassa dernière question
monsieur le président concernant la
participation de monsieur benalla dans
différentes opérations le secrétaire
général du syndicat des commissaires de
la police nationale monsieur le bar dit
il n'est pas diplômé en rien mais semble
avoir accès à tous qu'il a mandaté pour
cela quelle est votre réponse merci de
ces questions mes chers collègues
messieurs vous avez en tout et pour tout
au maximum cinq minutes pour nous
répondre et je vous laisse volontiers la
parole
on va essayer sur le lan cadre mans la
faune de l'apparence le grade de
lieutenant colonel de la réserve
spécialisés c'est une gestion
gendarmerie
effectivement on peut être interrogatif
monsieur vous avez confirmé je vous en
remercie mes propos concernant les
immersions dans le cadre de l'énergie en
particulier sur un encadrement bien pas
si un cadre bien précis qui était
régulièrement rappelé je précise aussi
que sur la d6 de la session 2010 et demi
de l'énergie les immersions n'ont donné
lieu à aucun problème je pense que c'est
important de le dire aussi
concernant le grade de lieutenant
colonel dans le cadre de la réserve
spécialisés il arrive que des policiers
sera aussi dans le peuple puisse être
dans le cadre de laser de spécialité
elles correspondent à un certain niveau
de diplôme de qualification et
d'expérience professionnelle qui ne
m'appartient pas ici de discuter sur le
niveau de qualification dont posséder
monsieur benalla puisque j'en ai pas
moi-même connaissance mais on peut se
poser la question à cet âge d'un grade
aussi élevé dans la réserve concernant
le la qualification de débordements nous
allons répondre à plusieurs sur le sur
l'ensemble des questions
le débordement c'est quand les forces de
police sont complètement dépassés ne
peuvent pas répondre à une situation qui
leur font perdre le terrain ou reculer
devant les manifestations ce qui
manifestement n'était pas le cas ce jour
là
concernant les photos prises par les par
les crs effectivement il des photos qui
ont été prises qui sont cesser les
documents qui ont été établies ce jour
là avec un document qu'on appelle de ces
petits mots qui confirme le fait que des
photos et des vidéos où ont été prises
après quand je parle d'une équipe de
trois il s'agit de mesures craintes ne
se dit merci monsieur benalla qui
semblait que les personnes qui étaient
ce jour-là c'était
imerys qui oui il salue trois personnes
qui ont d'ailleurs été confirmée par le
préfet de police hier puisqu'il a cité
il a cité ces non plus trois dépendant
des échelons dire est différent de la
hiérachie l'administration sur le reste
des questions je laisse mes collègues
répond en ce qui concerne le la présence
de monsieur benalla sur des
manifestations ou des services je crois
que c'est important de faire la
distinction puisque effectivement il ya
deux appellations
il ya eu un peu de confusion bien que
moi j'ai toujours employer le terme
service d'ordre pour être prudent on est
maintenant sûr que monsieur benalla
participer au maintien de l'ordre
celui du premier maire maintien de
l'ordre c'est lorsqu'il ya une
manifestation revendicative et en
particulier lorsqu'il ya des risques
avérés de mouvement à la différence d'un
service d'ordre qui est un service plus
figée plus officielle qui peut par
exemple être celui d'une visite
présidentielle pour l'est pour
lesquelles monsieur pénale a été présent
systématiquement un service d'ordre
parisien géré par là des opc pour autant
messieurs benalla étaient présents sur
nombre d'entre eux il y a également eu
mais ça votre commission l'établira avec
les différents témoignages des services
d'ordre qui ne concernaient pas
uniquement le déplacement du président
de la république puisque sam a également
été dit par des fonctionnaires de police
de la préfecture de police qui à ces
occasions on croiser régulièrement
monsieur benalla d'où le fait que pour
eux c'est est officielle et qu'il ne
s'en plaignait pas un exemple un
glisseur les boutons s'il vous plaît
pour que cette question soit entendu si
vous voulez bien nous dire tout
déplacement de qui il s'agissait
c'est le secrétaire général si vous le
savez vrai pont vers nous et je vais
vous répondre les déplacements du
président de la république
systématiquement il y avait la présence
de monsieur benalla mais il ya un
exemple de service d'or par exemple la
panthéonisation de madame simone veil
monsieur b dallas est également très
présent et actif voilà aussi bien en
amont que dans certains aspects du
dispositif
je réponds à la halle à ce qu'a dit le
préfet de police en parlant de dérives
individuelles
je lui ai toujours dit depuis le début
je représente les commissaires de police
ceux qui ont commis des dérives
individuelles les assumerons et
et s'en expliqueront mais il faut
rappeler quand même que monsieur
simoneau qui a été longuement cité dans
toutes les auditions étaient chef d'état
major adjoint de la ddt et aux pc à la
préfecture de police ce poste là n'est
pas du tout le haut de la pyramide c'est
un poste important mais ça n'est pas le
haut de la pyramide et ça n'est pas un
des postes sommitaux comme j'ai pu le
lire par ailleurs la préfecture de
police s'étaient contentés de façon très
qualitatif de des services de monsieur
simonin puisque c'est un grand
professionnel sur l'aspect maintien de
l'ordre et qu'on lui avait confiée on
sait la préfecture de police
tous les services d'ordre les plus
sensibles et c'est à cette occasion
qu'il a noué des liens par évidence avec
monsieur benalla puisque c'était son
interlocuteur côté elysée il faut aussi
le rappeler alors si on suit et ronces
et dans ses fonctions intérieur nature
des chefs d'état maliens sur dans ses
fonctions il était officiellement
d'interlocuteurs de monsieur benalla
puisque en face monsieur benalla était
l'interlocuteur de la préfecture de
police on le sait maintenant avec le
retour le recul qu'on perd un petit peu
à voir
je réponds à la question qui m'est un
peu plus ciblées après je laisserai la
parole à mon collègue pour la la
présence sur les maintien de lampes ce
qu'il a un point à préciser qui a
mandaté c'est un peu la même question
que précédemment qui a mandatés monsieur
ben alla pour avoir cette fonction là là
depuis le début je suis prudent moi
j'affirme juste qu'au vu de la présence
de cet individu récurrentes sur ces
services là ça n'est pas au niveau d'un
commissaire de police tout comme ton
tout contrôleur général qu'il soit à la
des opc qu'il faut se contenter
d'estimer que cette présence était
officialisée et permanente à son propre
niveau ou en tout cas si c'est à son
niveau que ça s'est passé au 1er mai ou
sur d'autres services
ça ne peut pas dans le système de la
préfecture de police être inconnu du
haut de la pyramide en sachant que les
différents commissaires ou cadres avec
qui j'ai pu parler à la préfecture de
police connaissent tous monsieur benalla
je vous remercie et d'autres précisions
monsieur alors très rapidement très
rapidement je souhaiterais apporter une
précision sur le point concernant la
présence d'individus sur des dispositifs
de maintien de l'ordre et notamment je
souhaiterais profité du travail de cette
commission sur les circonstances dans
lesquelles des personnes extérieures
forces de sécurité intérieure se
retrouve impliqué dans du maintien de
l'ordre pour attirer son attention sur
une situation que devons dénoncer
plusieurs fois en tant qu'organisation
auprès entendre des personnels
scientifiques puisque dans les deux plus
en plus dans les dispositifs de maintien
de l'ordre des personnels scientifiques
sont déployés pour procéder de la
captation d'image ou même à des
prélèvements aux fins d'identification
avec ce point de détail particuliers
c'est que le personnel scientifique à
l'heure actuelle est encore recruter
sous un statut administratif sédentaires
qui n'a donc à ce titre aucune formation
en maintien de l'ordre en utilisation
des équipements individuels de
protection ou même en autodéfense ce qui
à mon avis course qui s'ils continuent
situation dans laquelle du personnel qui
n'a pas vocation à se retrouver déployer
faire du maintien de l'ordre se trouvent
impliquées au plus près des des lieux où
la situation peut très vite débordés je
vous remercie
je vous remercie messieurs il me reste à
vous remercier des réponses que vous
nous avez apporté est aussi de vous être
pliée notre méthode de travail est assez
contraignante j'en conviens et nous
allons maintenant procéder à la dernière
audition avant la séance des questions
d'actualité
c'est l'audition de la fédération force
ouvrière
bien et messieurs je vous rappelle j'ai
le devoir de le faire qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission des
lois doté des prérogatives d'une
commission denquête serait passible de
cinq ans d'emprisonnement et de 75000
euros d'amendé
je dois vous faire prêter serment je
vous invite à le faire en dix ans toute
la vérité rien que la vérité levé la
main droite et dit je le jure je le vois
je vous remercie monsieur nous allons
vous laisser introduire nos échanges
étant entendu que il nous serait
agréable que votre intervention
liminaire soit concise de manière à
permettre à nos deux rapporteurs de vous
poser des questions vous y répondre et
puis les collègues sénateurs qui le se
retrouvent opposerons à leur tour
quelques questions et ne devons faire
tenir l'audition impérativement dans le
délai d'une demi heure au maximum car
nous rejoignons à 16h45 précise la
séance des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
voilà vous avez la parole oui a priori
seulement merci monsieur président bon
effectivement cette affaire défraye la
chronique et qui plus est je dirais la
chronique dans les rangs des policiers
les policiers de terrain que nous
représentons à savoir les gardiens de la
paix pourquoi pas ce manifestement les
les agissements aujourd'hui en jeter une
une suspicion dans nos rangs et ont
provoqué aussi manifestement une rupture
de confiance avec la hiérarchie
policière rupture de confiance qui était
déjà palpable
malheureusement depuis trop longtemps
mais qui aujourd'hui s'accentue pourquoi
passionnés policiers de terrain ceux qui
sont soumis à des contraintes je dirais
effréné lié à la menace terroriste mais
pas qu'à la menace terroriste
aujourd'hui ne comprennent pas comment
se fait ce qu'il ait fallu je dirais
l'article et la vidéo publiée par le
monde pour qu'apparaissent les
agissements ô combien punissable et
condamnable de cet individu
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui la les gardiens
de la paix se pose des questions se
posent des questions sur ce qui a pu se
passer en amont se pose des questions
j'ai eu l'occasion de m'exprimer à
plusieurs reprises dans les médias
et aujourd'hui on parle on a
l'impression aujourd'hui d'être
confrontés une police parallèle dit et
par certains
et je n'ai même employer un mot très
fort mais que dont j'assume la complète
responsabilité à savoir est ce que nous
étions confronté ni plus ni moins qu'à
des barbouzes alors les policiers
aujourd'hui sont en attente de décision
les policiers n'ont pas très bien
compris non plus je dirais l'ailé
les passages de témoins qui ont eu effet
entre les responsables de la préfecture
de police de paris entre autres et
aujourd'hui on a du mal à comprendre
nous gardiens de la paix on a du mal à
comprendre comment la haute dyarchie
policière de la préfecture de police
n'était pas au courant des agissements
de monsieur benalla et de quelques-uns
de ses comparses
voilà en quelques mots l'aider je pense
avoir suffisamment résumé avoir été
suffisamment concis pour pouvoir vous
donner l'état d'esprit aujourd'hui des
policiers que nous représentons
merci monsieur le président ne sait ce
que monsieur le secrétaire général je
vous prie de m'excuser de cette
intervention liminaire qui de surcroît
avec des camps 6 je vais demander à
madame jourdain de bien vouloir ouvrir
la séquence des questions merci monsieur
le président merci messieurs de votre
présence et je vous assure nom de de la
commission de tout l'intérêt la
considération que nous portons à votre
travail je voulais vous demander si vous
avez connaissance de ce qu'est le statut
d'observateur lorsque quelqu'un vient
sur une manifestation notamment maintien
de l'ordre comme ça a été le cas et ceux
qui régissent le statut et comment les
choses sont censés se passer pour la
personne qu'ils observent quelle tenue
kalt a le droit de faire et l
accompagner
deux statues à ma connaissance il y en a
point aujourd'hui effectivement on a
quelques années tous les deux de prises
derrière nous et on a été confronté à la
présence d'observateurs donc de statut
absolument pas le statut c'est une
personne qui demande
il est fréquent que ce soit des
journalistes parfois même des magistrats
souvent liés d'ailleurs par la session
de formation de l'institut des hautes
études de la sécurité de la justice
l'équipe manqué leur doit être un
équipement de protection donc le cas
présent dans le cas du du 1er mai que
monsieur benalla ait eu un cast c'est
tout à fait légitime
pourquoi nous sommes nous à maintien de
l'ordre qui étaient réputés est
difficile et qu'il fut d'ailleurs
particulièrement violent on a tous et
toutes en imitant encore en mémoire les
images de la fin de manifestation à côté
du pont d'austerlitz mais c'est tout ce
sont des sols le sol utilement qui peut
avoir
alors on peut accessoirement je les ai
vécus avoir parfois un observateur qui
puisse avoir un brassard police pourquoi
pas s'il faut également si on a
plusieurs je dirais unités
d'intervention au moment du maintien de
l'ordre
il faut qu'on puisse savoir si
réellement c'est un une personne
autorisée être en abords immédiats des
forces de l'ordre à part ça n'y a rien
cette personne l'observateur bas se doit
par définition d'observer et en aucun
cas se doit de permettre d'intervenir à
quelques moments qui ce soit sauf bien
évidemment comme le prétend aujourd'hui
monsieur benalla en fonction du code de
procédure pénale mais tel n'était pas le
cas ce jour là mes collègues aux crs
avaient une complète le maîtrisent la
situation
merci monsieur le secrétaire général
monsieur le président en sueur messieurs
les ce et rohs je vais simplement vous
demandez quel écho vous avez des
relations de vos collègues avec monsieur
benalla je vais vous demander aussi
puisque théoriquement je dis bien
théoriquement il n'existe pas de chaîne
de commandement entre monsieur benalla
et les personnels de la police ou de la
gendarmerie nationales qui sont sous
l'autorité du ministère de l'intérieur
et t
teulet hiérarchie de la police et de la
gendarmerie
et il arrivait que certaines certains de
vos collègues soit amené à s'opposer ou
à ne pas prendre en compte certaines
incitations pour parler de manière
modérée de monsieur banal à vous voyez
ce que je veux dire
et ne vous paraît-il ne vous paraître
est il pas souhaitable qu'il eut un
statut clairement définis pour ce qui
est de la protection du président de la
république et des hautes personnalités
qui prévoirait que cela relève
exclusivement de la notorité des
personnes compétentes et formé de la
police et de la gendarmerie nationale
alors ce qui concerne les relations de
monsieur benalla avec mes collègues du
groupe de sécurité du président la
république du gspr un tueur relève du
service de protection des hautes
personnalités
il ya une alternance en fonction du
président parfois ce sont nos collègues
gendarmes parfois ce sont nos collègues
policiers qui assurent cette protection
depuis la fin de semaine dernière les
langues commencent à se délier
manifestation manifestement pardon
monsieur benalla faisait régner la
terreur au sein du gspr
monsieur benalla n'hésitait pas d'après
les propos qui nous sont rapportées bien
évidemment nous n'étions pas témoin de
ces propos ni de ses agissements mais
semblerait manifestement que cette
personne allait jusqu'à l'insultent à
l'encontre des gradés et gardiens de la
paix avant même peut-être des officiers
constituant ce groupe
aujourd'hui il est bien évidemment pour
répondre à votre question il n'est pas
question aujourd'hui qu'un policier
puisse avoir à obéir à une personne qui
ne relèvent pas de la hiérarchie
policière
c'est complètement inconcevable bien
évidemment il ya le le statut du corps
préfectoral
mais ça on est dans un autre domaine
parce qu'en l'occurrence jamais un
préfet ne se permet d'ordonner un
policier sauf en passant bien évidemment
par sa hiérarchie directe mais là on est
vraiment dans un système pour le moins
opaque d'une personne
qui a tenté notamment là encore les
langues se délient d'avoir une
intimidation constante et récurrente et
d'avoir tenté de réformer le système de
sécurité du gspr notamment pour le fort
de brégançon
ces dernières semaines mon organisation
syndicale n'a jamais été associé à ce
débat je sais qu'il a tenté de le faire
et pour le coup effectivement une
organisation syndicale autre que la
l'autre s'est opposé légitimement à
cette tentative je dirais de
restructuration mais là on était
vraiment sur une personne qui qui jouait
de sa relation après le système
pourrait-on dire comment se fait-il que
des policiers puissent accepter d ordre
d instruction accepter autant peut-être
de quolibets sinon même d' insulte la
problème
la problématique se fonde sur le fait
que nous sommes inclus dans une chaîne
et hiérarchique aussi et que cette
personne avait quand même le statut de
chef de cabinet adjoint de l'élysée et
faisait régner la terreur à travers son
statut tout simplement vous savez quand
eu un gardien de la paix à un grade et
un officier voire même certainement un
commissaire en face de lui une personne
disant j'ai le une relation directe
constante et récurrente avec le
président de la république
peu d'entre nous sauf peut-être les
syndicalistes ce dont je suis convaincu
d'ailleurs au demeurant mais un
fonctionnaire de police et son shop et
jora type lambda ne s'opposera que très
rarement
il a le il incarnait à travers ses
propos son attitude une je dirais une
posture de pouvoir suprême
il faisait part le fait régner la
terreur merci de cette réponse très
claire
donc mes chers collègues et vous
connaissez la règle du jeu au maximum
une petite minute monsieur alain richard
sur secrétaire-général tout à l'heure
dans votre propos vous avez semblé
associés sous le nom de barbouzes à
monsieur benalla d'autres personnes sans
établir leur nombre vous sembliez site
est ce que vous appeliez des comparses
avez vous des éléments d'information qui
puisse nous être utile quant à une
pluralité de personnes ayant les mêmes
agissements
hors hiérarchie que monsieur benalla
entre autres nations et sénateurs nous
avons la personne qui a été je dirais
les prisons sûres par la vidéo
secrétaire général pour le jeu j'aurais
dû vous le préciser je suis désolé je
vais demander à chacun de mes collègues
de poser des questions notez-le et s'il
vous plaît et vous y répondre et d'un
seul coup ce qui nous permet d'être plus
synthétique c'est pour la bonne gestion
de notre audition et j'ai eu un moment
de distraction je vous prie de m'en
excuser
monsieur collombat vous avez parlé de
police parallèle à la police mais comme
chacun sait normalement les blés
parallèle ne se rejoignent pas là
visiblement elles se rejoignent est
quelque part à la préfecture de police
et lorsqu'il a été interrogé par nos
collègues de l'educ de l'assemblée
nationale le préfet de police de paris a
parlé à ce propos de copinage malsain
ce que vous avez une idée de par quel
mécanisme
ce personnage a pu a pu avoir cet
ascendant sur quand même des gens qui
sont pas nés de la dernière couvée enfin
a pu arriver à avoir autant de pouvoir
alors que c'était une usurpation pur
pure et simple est ce que ça nous
mettrait peut-être sur la sur la voie 2
des ventes ul réforme ou clarification
des rôles de chacun pour justement
sortir de cette ambiguïté qui luttent il
a servi merci cher collègue madame
eustache brinio oui messieurs tout à
l'heure vous avez parlé de quelqu'un qui
faisait régner prenons la terreur avec
un certain nombre de fonctionnaires moi
je voulais savoir depuis quand vous
connaissez l'existence de cette personne
au sein de l'elysée est ce qu'il est là
depuis longtemps est ce que il a été
intégré
aux côtés du président de la république
relativement tôt dans le cadre de ce
mandat parce que du coup aujourd'hui on
a l'air on comprend ce qui se passe avec
cette personne depuis tout à l'heure je
pense qu'on a eu d'aidé timoney rexel en
éclairant je veux savoir depuis quand
vous vous connaissez l'existence ce
personnage qui fait régner la terreur à
l'elysée merci merci chers que les gués
madame les pieds vous avez parlé
messieurs 2 vous avez dit que les crs
maîtriser la situation
1 l'avocat de monsieur ben ali a parlé
de débordements alors je voulais savoir
parce qu'ils disaient qu'ils étaient
venus en renfort et c'est un petit peu
seuil que j'aimerais que vous précisiez
je remercie scheer collègue monsieur
alain marc
j'aimerais pensez vous qu'il soit normal
que quelqu'un de de 26 ans et même si la
valeur n'attend pas le nombre des années
soit éventuellement chargé de
réorganiser le jus espère et comment
l'expliquez vous merci chers collègues
enfin madame marie mercier
merci monsieur le président messieurs
vous sembler quelque peu excédé par
cette histoire
j'aimerais savoir si dans votre carrière
vous avez déjà eu à faire un
comportement de ce genre tu vas merci
chers collègues
et enfin dernière question celle de
madame marie b ça rejoint un peu ce qui
a été dit il ya quelque chose qui
m'intrigue dans ce que vous dites vous
insistez énormément sur les
comportements déviants mais en même
temps derrière il ya un système qui
permet de se taire ces comportements
déviants
donc j'aimerais que vous nous aidiez à y
voir plus clair sur cette différence
très bien alors monsieur le secrétaire
général et monsieur le secrétaire
général délégué à vous de jouer
pour répondre à toutes ces questions
dans certaines images brésil direct
quand je reprendrai effectivement la
première est la question monsieur le
sénateur chat sur les d'autres comparses
ont hormis gelé dit tout à l'heure
hormis celui qui a été vu employés de la
république en marche un d'après ce qu'on
peut savoir
selon les éléments en ma possession il
semblerait manifestement qu'au sein du
gsp agen 6 2 bien sûr
semblerait avec le conditionnel qui
s'imposent qu'effectivement au sein du
j'espère nous avions un groupe un groupe
de deux personnels hors police et or
jean namory dans hors du champ de la
mission régalienne de sécurité qui doit
être celle du gsp à la protection du
président avec lui et de son épouse qui
en l'occurrence était d'aider des civils
des privés et c'est bien pour ça que
j'ai employé depuis le début depuis
jeudi dernier jean pas le terme de
barbouzes parce que ces gens là n'ont
une habilitation
ce ne sont ni plus ni moins que sans que
ce soit péjoratif que j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour les métiers de la sécurité
privée
mais ce sont des vigiles qui était
employé aujourd'hui manifestement par
monsieur benalla dans le cadre de la
protection de la présidence de la
république
oui effectivement monsieur le secrétaire
général cette information que vous nous
donnez est extrêmement importante est ce
que vous êtes en mesure de la source et
achever la source et moi j'ai les
renseignements que j'ai c'est bien
évidemment à travers nos réseaux de
délégués au sein du service de
protection des hautes personnalités sphp
et bien évidemment par part est fait je
dirais sur le gspr les éléments que j'ai
eus m'ont été rapportés effectivement
par mes représentants locaux qui m'ont
dit effectivement qui m'ont affirmé
qu'ils avaient des groupes de 2,2 privé
qu'il travaillait en l'occurrence avec
monsieur benalla et qui est provoqué
justement détention avéré entre eux les
fonctionnaires de police et monsieur
benalla et ses comparses qui en
l'occurrence et ça serait d'ailleurs un
des motifs de la réorganisation du gspr
dans la perspective de la protection du
fort de brégançon pendant les vacances
du président monsieur le secrétaire
général est ce que vos correspondants
vous vous ont indiqué le nombre de
vigiles que non je n'ai pas je n'ai pas
nombre précis monsieur le président mais
on peut s'en enquérir et je ne manquerai
pas de porter à votre connaissance si
vous me le permettez de tels
renseignements et je ne vous le permet
pas je vous le demande bien reçu
monsieur le président j'ai voulu
nécessaires à la collecte du
renseignement va sans âme et sans délai
je vous remercie et
vous avez vous êtes d'autres 6e nous
apporter non pas ce port ce domaine
voilà madame j'entends madame eustache
brinio et je pose à sa place la question
depuis quand le savez vous éprouvez vous
pourrez vous nous l'indiqué aussi je
pourrais je pourrais je pourrais vous
l'indiquez effectivement les langues se
délient parce que vous comprenez
aisément que quand on a essayé d'avoir
des renseignements le week-end dernier
il y avait je dirais une chape de plomb
est quelque peu d'aidé des refus de
répondre à nos sollicitations la matière
ce qui se comprend aisément depuis les
fonctionnaires qui sont affectés aux
j'espère qu'ils ont un devoir de réserve
en l'état seuls les représentants du
personnel pourront s'enquérir de la
chose et on essaiera d'avoir le maximum
de renseignements pour que l'on puisse
apporter des éléments nécessaires à
l'enquêté
messieurs oui monsieur chauvette vous
voulez apporter des précisions mais
simplement apporter une précision mais
qui est qui doit être évidente à mon
sens pour tout le monde sait que compte
tenu de la sensibilité de cette affaire
et de l'endroit où était affecté entre
guillemets monsieur benalla c'est à dire
ni plus ni moins dans la proximité du
président de la république il arborait
systématiquement sa carte
à n'importe quel fonctionnaire qui est
rencontraient du cabinet donc de
l'elysée il est bien évident que faire
parler nos collègues et je répond
directement à la question précédemment
que ce soit à l'égard des gradés et
gardiens de la paix mais aussi la
moyenne est archi les officiers et les
commissaires personne n'allait se
répandre sur des travers qui auraient pu
été effectués et semble-t-il puisque
secrétaire général vient d'annoncer qu
effectivement les langues se délient on
apprend qu'il ya eu plusieurs quoi
qu'ils n'étaient pas de même niveau
certes mais qui à la fois faisait état
d' altercation avec les forces de police
et de gendarmerie sur certains maintien
de l'ordre où il souhaitait prendre la
tête du dispositif ou détourné l'action
de la police nationale sur certaines
interventions et qui plus est pour ceux
qui éventuellement pouvait trouver ça
totalement anormal et éventuellement le
faire savoir
et bien il y avait effectivement cette
carte qu'il présentait qu'il arborait
que là pour le coup c'était plus
difficile à faire savoir mais gare au
déroulement carrière que vous pouvez
bien comprendre c'est chouette c'est
très important ce que veut dire je vous
en remercie mais cela appelle de ma part
une question complémentaire quelques
couacs pouvez vous les décrire
alors effectivement il a été porté à
notre connaissance mais on pourra amener
des précisions encore plus clair
d après c'est que assez régulièrement la
présence de monsieur benalla sur des
manifestations où il était forcément
autorisés à y aller et sur ces
manifestations et bien systématiquement
il il essayait de prendre la main sur le
dispositif y compris auprès de hauts
gradés et certains de nos collègues
nombre de nos représentants ont pu
confirmer qu'il y avait eu des tensions
et où il a été écarté par le fait qu' il
souhaitait intervenir ou décider de
telle ou telle manipulation des
effectifs donc vous voulez dire que
l'autorité de police s'est refusée à ce
moment-là à déférer à ses ordres à ses
instructions à ses recommandations wii
ou à sa volonté d agir autrement
très bien je vous remercie madame
benbassa brune ultime question nous
avons juste te remercie monsieur le
président une toute petite question
pourquoi pourquoi cette sécurité privée
qui prend la place de la police à
l'elysée mais quel est l'objectif
pourquoi cette sécurité privée c'est ces
personnes que vous appelez des barbouzes
à côté de la police qui remplissait au
j'espère l'aca fonctions de sécurité du
président merci je préside je reprends
je réponds dessus de réponse à la
question madame vous savez madame la
sénatrice
très franchement je crois que c'est au
président de répliques qui vous pose la
question en la matière sinon monsieur
avait un monsieur benalla pourquoi ou
sans doute à monsieur le directeur de
cabinet de l'elysée nous pour ça on ne
sait pas on apprend ces choses ou petit
au fur et à mesure voilà talent une
question m'a été posée depuis quand je
connais monsieur benalla très simplement
j'ai été reçu par président la
république à la fin du mois de janvier
dans le cas de des changes bien
évidemment dans le cadre du dialogue
social qui s'imposaient prison n'avait
plus il voulait s'enquérir de l'état des
des forces de sécurité d'autres
républiques de notre belle république
et j'ai croisés dans un établissement
public chez croisé cette personne sans
savoir qui c'était c'est quand j'ai vu
ces photos à paraître dans tous les
médias de france ils ont même du monde
entier mercredi et jeudi que je me suis
remémoré avoir vu cette personne qui
n'avait de cesse déjà les potes de
parler de 2 de son étui pour son arme et
pour moi et mon collègue qui étaient
présents ce jour là pour nous il
s'agissait d'un collègue policier du
gspr
ils avaient tous les latitudes et preuve
en est faite ils avaient tous les
attributs et je vous fais grâce de la
voiture c'était une journée c'était un
lundi matin de très bonne heure dans un
bar pas très éloigné à mi chemin entre
entre beauvau et l'elysée madame voyez
vous voyez alors s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît il faut qu alors qu'il y ait
ici aussi une certaine police de notre
commission et le rôle ingrat que
j'accepte d'assumer ses de l'exercer
mais je le fais à titre officiel
alors monsieur le secrétaire génaral y
ajouter quelque chose mais moi je vais
vous rappeler aussi qu'il nous veut
qu'il vous faut répondre à la question
de madame marie mercier tout à l'heure à
laquelle vous n'avez pas répondu qui
vous a demandé si dans votre expérience
de policiers vous avez déjà rencontré ce
type d' usurpation d'autorité venant
d'un collaborateur de la présidence de
la république voilà alors je vous laisse
reprendre la parole n'ont jamais non
jamais j'ai 36 ans de police nationale
derrière moi j'ai beaucoup de maintien
de l'ordre
je n'ai jamais été confronté à ce genre
d'agissements jamais jamais jamais dieu
jamais il ya aussi une question monsieur
le président si on veut rester sur le
sur le l'âge 26 ans 26 ans 26 ans vous
savez unité sgp police force ouvrière
n'a de cesse de lutter syndicalement
parlant pour permettre à nos collègues
d'obtenir le grade supérieur légitimes
attentes légitimes attentes
aujourd'hui pour accéder au grade de
brigadier-chef quand on est brigadier
sur moyenne 15 à 20 ans et il faut
surtout pas être trop cher de police
dans la creuse dans les landes
au pays basque où dans le morbihan parce
que là ça sera 35 ou 40 ans sinon même
dans les antilles d'envoyer c'est pour
nous c'est proprement parler scandaleux
comment cet individu à 26 ans est nommé
lieutenant colonel en l'occurrence la
cie véritablement une insulte à nos
camarades d'armes que sont nos collègues
gendarmes
donc c'est une insulte effectivement on
peut faire valoir le côté expertise mais
passez moi du peu l' expertise en la
matière est complètement irrecevable sur
la la question va je dirais la lame la
mise en avant par les avocats de
monsieur benalla du fait que nos
collègues crs étaient débordés le
premier mais je suis intervenu à
plusieurs reprises dans les médias en
disant que le premier mais même si ça a
peut-être tarder un peu l'intervention
devant le mcdonald's et devant la
concession auto à hauteur du pont
d'austerlitz j'ai considéré à l'époque
que les effectifs étaient largement
dimensionnés on n'était pas en sous
dimensionnement on était largement bien
dimensionné et qu'en l'occurrence dans
un tel cas il valait mieux attendre
malheureusement valait mieux je dirais
constaté des dégâts matériels que
d'avoir concédé des dégâts humains tant
qu en aucun cas les crs n'ont été en
position d'être débordés même sur cette
place le 1er mai absolument pas je ne
complète maîtrise de la situation
les crs se sont des professionnels
reconnus dans le monde entier en matière
de gestion du maintien de l'ordre au
même titre d'ailleurs que gendarmes
mobiles poche il faut associer nos
collègues gendarmes en la matière l'oni
a jamais été question de débordement le
fait de devoir à tout prix saisir au vu
d'un article du code de procédure pénale
faire saisir ces c'est une infraction
franchement franchement c'est fait à
l'eau de rose s'est indûment terre
passez moi l'expression bien mais c'est
le seul titre de secrétaire général et
monsieur le secrétaire général délégué
je tiens à vous remercier de la
franchise et du courage de votre
expression devant la commission des lois
du sénat
c'est bien ce que nous attendions de
vous